en application des articles 29 et 30 de
la Constitution je déclare ouverte la
session extraordinaire convoquée par
décret du Président de la République du
19 juin 2023
mes chers collègues cette nuit un jeune
caporat de chef de la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris est décédé à
la suite d'une intervention sur un
incendie nous savons combien est grand
le dévouement des soldats du feu ce
drame terrible nous l'a malheureusement
rappelé en mémoire de la victime et en
soutien à sa famille à ses proches et à
ses collègues je vous invite à observer
une minute de silence
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée du projet de loi adopté par le
Sénat d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de la Justice 2023 2027 et
du projet de loi organique adopté par le
Sénat relatif à l'ouverture la
modernisation et la responsabilité du
corps judiciaire la Conférence des
Présidents a décidé que ces deux textes
donneraient lieu à une discussion
générale commune avant de donner la
parole aux guerres de des sceaux je vous
informe qu'à la demande de la commission
des lois constitutionnelles de la
législation et de l'administration
générale de la République en application
l'article 95 alinéa 4 du Règlement la
discussion de l'article 1er et du
rapport annexé ainsi que des amendements
portant articles additionnels après
l'article premier est réservé ils seront
examinés après l'article 29
la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur général mais si
les rapporteurs madame la rapporteur
pour avis
mesdames et messieurs les députés
avant de commencer je veux ici rendre
hommage aux jeunes caporal chef
d'Orient d'amelincourt
mort au feu cette nuit alors qu'il
exerçait avec bravoure sa courageuse
mission de sapeurs-pompiers
mesdames et messieurs les députés
plus que jamais notre pays
et nos concitoyens
nous tous
avons besoin de justice
plus que jamais notre justice
nos magistrats
nous greffiers nos agents pénitentiaires
nos conseillers d'insertion et de
probation et tous ceux qui la servent
avec dévouement et qui sont aujourd'hui
mobilisés
ont besoin de nous
ils ont besoin que dans un geste fort
dans un élan sans précédent
nous donnions collectivement à la
justice
les moyens nécessaires à
l'accomplissement de son impérieuse
mission
maintenir la paix civile
il nous appartient dans les débats qui
commencent de répondre ensemble
et en responsabilité à ce besoin
régalien fort
ce sont plus de 8 mois d'un temps
travaux pour sonder les difficultés de
l'institution judiciaire et plus d'un
million de contributions citoyennes
réunies dans le rapport des États
généraux ce sont deux grandes vagues de
concertation l'année dernière avec tous
les acteurs du monde judiciaire c'est
aussi la présentation d'un plan d'action
global pour la justice en début d'année
c'est enfin un vote sans appel par le
Sénat le mois dernier
ce sont toutes ces étapes qui ont fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes réunis pour
discuter de la première traduction
législative et organique de ce plan
d'action
comme si était engagé le président de la
République et la première ministre je
suis venu vous présenter les lois de
programmation et de réforme du statut de
la magistrature les plus ambitieuses de
l'histoire du ministère de la Justice
comme je l'avais dit lors de ma prise de
fonction je suis venu avec vous
tournez la page des mauvaises habitudes
qui gangrènent notre justice depuis de
trop nombreuses années
la première d'entre toutes et celle qui
consiste à demander toujours plus à la
justice en lui donnant toujours moins
je suis venu mesdames et messieurs les
députés écrire avec vous
un nouveau chapitre celui de la justice
enfin doté à la hauteur de ses missions
et une justice qui serait considérée à
sa juste place au coeur de la cité le
chemin est long mais le cap est bon et
le pas résolumentation
une autre mauvaise habitude et celle
d'avoir en matière de justice une
approche parcellaire
or le plan d'action pour la justice
concerne toutes les matières pénales
civiles commerciales
organisationnel et utilise tous les
leviers législatif organique budgétaire
et réglementaire
la dernière est sans doute la pire des
habitudes et celle de ne pas placer au
cœur des réformes le justiciable je le
dis clairement
ce plan d'action et ses projets de loi
ont l'ambition de répondre concrètement
aux attentes de nos concitoyens
au premier rang desquels celle d'une
justice plus proche
plus efficace plus rapide
l'un des objectifs est clair il est
ambitieux divisé par deux l'ensemble des
délais de justice d'ici 2027
notre priorité absolue est donc celle de
donner à la justice les moyens
nécessaires pour être à la hauteur de sa
mission
l'article premier de la loi de
programmation du ministère de la Justice
entérine une augmentation sans précédent
des crédits de la justice qui
atteindront près de 11 milliards en 2027
sur les cinq prochaines années cumulées
les crédits du ministère de la Justice
augmenteront de près de
7,5 milliards d'euros pour bien
comprendre ce que cela représente ils
ont augmenté de 2 milliards d'euros sous
le quinquennat du président Sarkozy et
de 2,1 milliard d'euros sous celui du
président Hollande
de manière concrète ces crédits massifs
vont poursuivre quatre objectifs qui
embrassent de façon globale les enjeux
du service public de la justice
premièrement
la mère des batailles c'est d'abord les
recrutements massifs et rapides de
magistrats de greffiers d'attacher de
justice d'agent pénitentiaire d'agents
administratifs bref de tous ceux qui
font vivre le ministère de la Justice
pour graver cela dans le marbre j'ai
souhaité inscrire dans la loi le
recrutement de 10000 personnels
supplémentaires
en création nette de postes disciples
2027 dont 1500 magistrats
[Applaudissements]
autant que sur les vins dernière années
cumulées
et au moins 1500 greffiers
je remercie votre rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des finances Perrine
Goulet qui a souhaité revenir à l'épure
initiale du texte pour donner au
ministère de la Justice la latitude
nécessaire pour gérer au mieux ce
contingent
le deuxième objectif c'est la
revalorisation de ce qui servent notre
justice au quotidien
pour recruter massivement il faut
attirer les talents vers le monde de la
justice
c'est pourquoi cette loi de
programmation entérine d'importantes
revalorisation des métiers judiciaires
une hausse de 1000 euros mensuels pour
les magistrats qui sera effectivement
dès l'automne pour récompenser et
encourager leur engagement quotidien
une revalorisation des greffiers sans
qui je le dis avec force la justice ne
pourrait pas fonctionner qui se fera
dans un calendrier dédié de négociations
là aussi à l'automne
le passage historique puisqu'il est été
réclamé par les syndicats depuis 20 ans
des agents pénitentiaires de la
catégorie C vers la catégorie B et pour
les officiers de la catégorie B vers la
catégorie A il était grand temps de
reconnaître le rôle indispensable de la
troisième force de sécurité
intérieure de notre pays je suis fier
non seulement d'être leur ministre mais
d'avoir amélioré leur place dans la
fonction publique
troisièmement nous allons mener à bien
la transformation numérique du ministère
de la Justice
qui a longtemps péché en la matière les
magistrats et les greffiers de terrain
vous le disent souvent ils sont freinés
par une informatique et un réseau qui ne
sont pas à la hauteur le but est clair à
l'instar de la juridiction
administrative il faut instaurer le zéro
papier à l'horizon 2027 pour cela nous
avons une méthode nous dotons toutes les
juridictions de techniciens
informatiques dédiées pour agir au plus
près du terrain avec le savoir-faire
requis lorsque la bécane plante et ça
arrive malheureusement trop souvent nous
augmentons massivement la capacité des
réseaux du ministère pour fluidifier les
connexions à terme l'objectif est aussi
d'avoir un seul compte pour accéder à
toutes les applications informatiques
afin d'éviter les doublons de saisine
notamment des greffiers qui leur font
perdre un temps précieux nous
la mise à jour concertée avec le terrain
des logiciels en matière civile je pense
par exemple à Portalis en matière pénale
cette loi de programmation accélérera le
déploiement des gens en cours de la
procédure pénale numérique en lien avec
le ministère de l'intérieur avec un chef
de fil unique
issu d'ailleurs de la Chancellerie la
transformation numérique de la justice
doit également se faire en direction de
ce qu'elle sert c'est à dire les
Justiciers
le lendemain le lancement d'une
application smartphone
regroupant des fonctionnalités
importantes ces choses faites
puisqu'elle a été lancée en avril
dernier dans une version qui permet déjà
de savoir si oui ou non vous êtes
éligibles à l'aide juridictionnelle ou
de simuler le montant d'une pension
alimentaire
le dernier objectif dans la cohérence de
notre plan concerne bien sûr le
programme immobilier du ministère de la
Justice d'abord l'immobilier judiciaire
c'est-à-dire la construction de
tribunaux l'arrivée des recrutements
massifs va nécessiter une augmentation
et une rénovation massive du parc
judiciaire c'est pourquoi nous avons une
vision globale qui prévoit d'investir de
manière importante dans les tribunaux de
demain pour améliorer les conditions de
travail de ceux qui servent à la justice
car en bout de chaîne c'est bien le
justiciable qui en bénéficiera
pleinement concrètement d'ici 2027 nous
engagerons plus de 40 opérations de
restructuration et de rénovation de
tribunaux et cour d'appel ensuite
il y a bien sûr le programme immobilier
pénitentiaire qui avance sûrement malgré
les nombreux freins comme la crise
sanitaire qui si elle est fort
heureusement derrière nous à durablement
impacté les chantiers
la guerre en Ukraine ensuite qui a
réduit l'accès aux matières premières et
bien sûr les réticences dériverains et
souvent de leurs élus notre engagement
est clair et le cap est clairement fixé
nous construirons 15000 places
supplémentaires d'ici 2027 l'année
prochaine la moitié des établissements
de ce plan sera sorti de terre
il en va d'abord de la bonne application
de la politique pénale qui est sans
aucune ambiguïté fermeté sans démagogie
humanisme sans angélisme il en va
ensuite bien sûr des conditions de
détention qui sont parfois indignes mais
aussi des conditions de travail du
personnel pénitentiaire je fais le tour
des prisons mesdames et messieurs les
députés depuis plus de 40 ans je connais
la dégradation d'un certain nombre
d'établissements mais
je n'ai pas contrairement à d'autres de
baguettes magiques je n'ai qu'une
volonté politique forte avec des leviers
d'action réalistes et des moyens inédits
car en matière pénitentiaire comme en
matière pénale d'ailleurs il faut se
méfier des solutions clés en main la
construction de prison et la solution la
plus lente mais la plus sûre surtout
qu'en parallèle des constructions nous
investissons massivement dans des
rénovations près de 130 millions d'euros
par an près de deux fois plus que sous
le quinquennat de François Hollande le
président sauvé ladite en ces mots
tout ne se résume pas à la question des
moyens c'est pourquoi je vous propose
une série de mesures qui viennent
réformer en profondeur l'institution
sans pour autant la déstabiliser car oui
des innovations de cette loi de réforme
de la justice c'est de mettre face aux
réforme les moyens nécessaires pour les
appliquer correctement
mesdames et messieurs les députés
la première réforme est celle de
l'amélioration de l'organisation de la
justice selon une approche innovante et
pragmatique je souhaite accélérer la
déconcentration du ministère de la
Justice en laissant plus d'autonomie au
juridictions dans leur administration
afin de ne faire intervenir
l'administration centrale que
lorsqu'elle est allée à la fois
utile en termes de support ou nécessaire
en termes d'arbitrage cette nouvelle
étape relève en grande partie du niveau
réglementaire et se fera d'ici l'automne
j'ai souhaité inscrire cette orientation
claire dans le rapport annexé car une
organisation plus efficace de la justice
c'est aussi des moyens mieux employés au
plus près des professionnels et des
justiciables
l'amélioration de l'organisation
des juridictions passent aussi par des
expérimentations innovantes pour
améliorer concrètement le service rendu
au justicien c'est ce que nous proposons
à travers l'expérimentation d'un
véritable tribunal des activités
économiques car l'organisation actuelle
des juridictions commerciales manquent à
l'évidence de lisibilité pour les
justiciables et pour les différents
acteurs je vous propose également
d'expérimenter une contribution
économique comme cela se pratique dans
divers pays européens afin notamment de
lutter contre les recours abusifs et
d'inciter à l'amiable cette contribution
permettra aussi de bénéficier de l'effet
de marques car souvent dans le monde
économique ce qui est gratuit est en
réalité perçue comme de moindre qualité
elle tiendra compte de la capacité
contributive du demandeur
bien sûr et du montant de la demande je
vois ici remercier l'action du
rapporteur général terrier et du
rapporteur Pradal qui ont permis
d'apaiser un certain nombre de crainte
concernant ces expérimentations
novatrices
une amélioration de l'organisation de
nos juridictions doit être aussi être
opérée dans les politiques pénales
prioritaires je pense bien sûr
à la question de la lutte contre les
violences intrafamilales avec la
création des pôles spécialisés
pôle spécialisée vif conformément au
rapport de grandes qualités rendus par
la députée Émilie Chandler et la
sénatrice Dominique Verrien cette
nouvelle organisation désormais inscrite
dans le rapport annexé sera traduite
dans le code de l'organisation
judiciaire par un décret qui vous sera
transmis et pris à l'été le texte en
débat portera également grâce à la
présidente Naïma mucho
une ambition forte en matière de justice
restaurative afin que d'ici 2027 tous
les tribunaux soient en mesure d'avoir
une offre en la matière pour les
justiciersiables en matière d'insertion
et de probation les travaux de la député
Caroline abatty permettront d'accélérer
la procédure en réduisant les délais de
convocation devant le juge de
l'application des peines pour permettre
une exécution plus rapide des peines
prononcées
les débats en commission ont également
permis des adaptations à nos outre-mer
grâce à l'amendement du président
Houlier afin de répondre concrètement
aux besoins notamment antillais en
matière de vision un mot aussi mesdames
et messieurs les députés pour souligner
que nous acterons une petite révolution
en matière de compétence universelle de
la justice française en matière de crime
contre l'humanité grâce au travail sans
relâche de votre collègue Gouffier
Valentin
la seule réforme
est celle de la modernisation des
ressources humaines
magistrats et fonctionnaires de la
Chancellerie
je compte employer tous les leviers
à notre disposition pour s'assurer que
non seulement le plan de recrutement
sera réalisé mais surtout qu'il
correspondra aux besoins du terrain
cette modernisation implique d'abord une
adaptation de ces ressources à la
réalité d'aujourd'hui
et notamment celle de la diversification
des fonctions je pense par exemple au
travail formidable réalisé par les
contractuels dans toutes nos
juridictions
le recrutement et l'engagement des
magistrats et greffiers a déjà permis de
réduire les stocks de près de 30% dans
les juridictions pour la première fois
depuis des décennies moins de stocks
c'est évidemment moins d'attente pour
nos concitoyens c'est pourquoi en plus
des recrutements massifs de magistrats
et greffiers la loi de programmation
vous propose non seulement de pérenniser
ces emplois on les sédiant mais
également de les institutionnaliser en
créant la fonction d'attacher de justice
comme l'avait appelé de ses vœux le
rapporteur général
ces attachés de justice seront formés à
l'ENM et prêteront il viendront
compléter et constituer une véritable
équipe autour du magistrat qui constitue
la vraie révolution à venir au sein de
la justice
c'est cette même impulsion
que nous souhaitons donner à
l'administration pénitentiaire avec la
possibilité de recruter des surveillants
adjoints par voie contractuelle ça a
fait ses preuves au ministère de
l'Intérieur j'ajoute d'ailleurs qu'en
termes d'attractivité le recrutement de
contractuels permet d'embaucher des
personnels au plus près des
établissements pénitentiaires
le chantier majeur de la modernisation
des ressources humaines et bien sûr
celui porté dans le projet de loi
organique c'est-à-dire la réforme du
statut de la magistrature et je veux ici
remercier le rapporteur Didier Paris
pour son engagement et la connaissance
fine qu'il a de la matière et qu'il a
mis au service de cette réforme cette
dernière repose sur trois axes
l'ouverture du corps judiciaire d'abord
recruté 1500 magistrats va nécessiter de
faciliter l'accès à la magistrature pour
cela nous proposons la création de
magistrats en service extraordinaire
mais également l'ouverture de
recrutement simplifiant les différentes
voies d'accès notamment pour les avocats
et en professionnalisant le recrutement
par l'instauration d'un jury
professionnel
le maintien du principe du concours
républicain nous garantira l'excellence
du niveau de recrutement l'objectif est
aussi d'assouplir les règles pour les
magistrats titres temporaires qui font
un travail
indispensable remarquable et seront
nécessaires pour la mise en œuvre de la
politique de l'amiable et les cours
criminels départementales enfin s'agite
également de simplifier certaines règles
de gestion des ressources humaines comme
la pérennisation des brigades de soutien
de magistrats greffiers qui font leurs
preuves à Mayotte et en Guyane la mise
en place des priorités d'affectation des
magistrats qui ont accepté de partir
dans des territoires peu attractifs la
création d'un troisième grade pour
garder des magistrats d'expérience de
première instance afin notamment
d'améliorer la qualité de la première
instance conform ément au vœu du rapport
sauvé
le deuxième axe de la réforme statutaire
repose sur la modernisation et notamment
celle du dialogue social ou du mode de
scrutin au Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature enfin le dernier axe se
repose sur la responsabilité du corps
judiciaire avec notamment
l'élargissement des conditions de
recevabilité des plaintes des
justiciables contre des magistrats
devant le Conseil supérieur de la
magistrature qui aujourd'hui ne donne
infinie jamais lieu à sanction
le troisième sentier de la réforme est
celui de la simplification d'un certain
nombre de procédures qu'elles soient
civile ou pénales elles sont un facteur
de complexité pour nos professionnels et
d'éloignement entre le citoyen et sa
justice vous le savez
en matière civile je veux faire enfin
advenir la révolution de l'amiable qui
se fait tant attendre dans notre pays
c'est très fort mais de niveau
réglementaire
j'ai transmis à la commission des lois
le projet de décret concernant la mise
en place de la césure et de l'audience
de règlement amiable afin que nous
puissions échanger sur ce point dans les
semaines à venir dans un temps plus long
ma porte vous le savez et grande ouverte
bien sûr pour échanger sur ces questions
en matière pénale je souhaite que nous
puissions lancer ensemble le chantier
titanesque de la simplification de la
procédure pénale s'agit dans un premier
temps de restructurer et de clarifier le
code de procédure pénale à droit
constant comme le précise l'article 2
l'objectif est de rendre plus lisible
pour les professionnels le code de pénal
réécrire des articles qui sont écrits
par envoi successifs à d'autres articles
réorganiser l'ensemble des chapitres et
regrouper certains textes aux épars pour
éviter tout simplement des erreurs
procédurales enfin je vous confirme que
le nouveau code de procédure pénale
n'entrera pas en vigueur avant sa
ratification comme ce fut le cas pour le
code justice pénale des mineurs le
comité parlementaire que nous
renforcerons dans le rapport annexé
grâce au travail du député Mondon qui
sera institué après la promulgation de
la loi permettra bien sûr de s'assurer
que le Parlement conserve bien un droit
de regard incontournable sur la conduite
de cette réforme enfin
et j'en terminerai par là il vous est
proposé une série de mesures concrètes
immédiatement applicable je pense par
exemple à des mesures améliorant
l'efficacité de l'enquête pénale
et on renforçant des techniques
spéciales d'enquête je ne méconnais pas
les craintes en la matière qui se sont
d'ores et déjà exprimés mais je pense
que le travail du rapporteur Balanant a
permis d'apporter un certain nombre de
garanties qui devrait nous rassurer tous
je pense à l'extension du travail
d'intérêt général aux entreprises de
l'économie sociale et solidaire si le
nombre de places ça signifie
ces dernières années sous l'impulsion de
cette majorité il nous faut à l'évidence
aller plus loin et c'est ce que
permettra un amendement de la députée
Blandine Broca je pense enfin à
l'extension du champ des infractions
recevables pour une indemnisation des
victimes le travail fait par les
rapporteurs et la député tanzilline nous
permettra là encore d'aller plus loin
afin de couvrir les victimes par
ricochet des victimes mineures
pour conclure mon propos
j'en reviendrai à mon point initial il
est de notre responsabilité collective
de répondre aux besoins de justice et de
donner à notre justice les moyens de
tenir son grand dans nos institutions
si nous avons certaines divergences sur
lesquelles nous reviendrons lors de
l'examen des amendements je sais que sur
la majorité de ces bancs de droite à
gauche nous partisons nous partageons
l'ambition commune et impérieuse
de vouloir restaurer la place de la
justice à la hauteur de la mission
fondamentale qui est la sienne à la
hauteur de l'engagement de ceux qui la
servent et surtout mesdames et messieurs
les députés à la hauteur des attentes
des Français au nom de qui ne l'oublions
jamais la justice est rendue
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Jean tardier
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
République pour le projet loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de la Justice 2023 2027
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues le projet de
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de la Justice est devenu un
rendez-vous quinquennal incontournable
pour le Parlement c'est une pratique
encore récente mais nous y sommes
attachés car elle donne l'occasion au
Parlement d'être informé en détail sur
les projets du gouvernement pour les 5
années à venir et sur les moyens qui
seront mis en oeuvre pour y parvenir
elle nous permet également de nous
exprimer grâce aux rapports annexés sur
des questions stratégiques y compris au
niveau réglementaire c'est enfin
l'occasion de procéder à des
améliorations dans les différents pans
du droit d'engager des réformes de
grande ampleur je pense à la réforme du
code de procédure pénale ou encore de
lancer des expérimentations je pense ici
au tribunaux des affaires économiques la
procédure la présence loi de
programmation que nous avions débattue
avec votre précédent avec votre
prédécesseur pardon Nicole Belloubet
avait permis d'engager de grandes
transformations pour notre justice et
qui se sont depuis concrétisés avec
succès la création de tribunaux
judiciaires et du parquet nationale
antiterroriste le développement des
moines alternatifs de règlement des
litiges la création du code de justice
pénale des mineurs et des cours
criminels tout au long du quinquennat
nous avons eu de cesse de réformer notre
justice la responsabilité pénale les
violences intrafamilales la lutte contre
la haine en ligne l'accès au travail des
détenus tout cela aurait été inutile
sans inconvénient financier fort mais
dans un contexte de tension sur nos
finances publiques nous avons maintenu
une hausse sans précédent du budget de
la justice plusuit pour cent 2021 plus
8% en 2022 je suis 8% en 2023 transformé
en service public comme celui de la
justice ne se fait pas en un jour tant
qu'il les tailles étaient affaibli par
les sous-investissements chroniques des
gouvernements précédents de gauche comme
de droite il est toujours plus facile
d'entendre ce qui nous conforte et nous
rassure pourtant vous avez eu l'audace
monsieur le garde des sceaux à
l'occasion des états généraux de la
justice de donner carte blanche au
professionnel pour qu'il vous adresse
après plusieurs mois de travail leur
constats leur proposition d'amélioration
en la franchise en toute transparence
sans interférence politique nous tirons
5 objectifs du présent projet de loi
réduire les délais au pénal comme au
civils simplifier moderniser les
procédures notamment s'appuyant sur la
numérique et les nouvelles technologies
revaloriser tous les métiers de la
justice par une meilleure gestion des
carrières de la formation et de la
mobilité répondre à la situation de nos
prisons confrontés à la surpopulation
carcérale et enfin poursuivre l'effort
financiers nécessaires à l'atteinte de
ses objectifs et à la modernisation de
l'institution judiciaire après des
débats de grande qualité en commission
nous avons pu améliorer le texte en
adoptant des amendements de la majorité
et de l'ensemble des groupes
d'opposition je vais décliner rapidement
les mesures contenues dans le projet de
loi dont j'ai eu spécifiquement la
charge je laisserai mes collègues Erwan
Balan et Philippe Pradal complété j'en
profite pour les remercier pour la
qualité du travail que nous avons mené
ensemble ainsi que nos précieux
administrateurs qui ont comme à leur
habitude fournit un travail d'une grande
qualité
le titre 4 porte sur l'ouverture et la
modernisation de l'institution
judiciaire il crée la fonction
d'attacher de justice qui se substitue
au juriste assistant nous avons
commission des lois actées qu'ils auront
qu'ils devront avoir au moins un bac + 5
pour être recruté en tant que
contractuel les contrats proposés seront
à durée indéterminés une réelle avancée
par rapport au statut précaire des
juristes assistants aujourd'hui et
surtout une reconnaissance de leur
importance au sein des juridictions il
constate la participation des
parlementaires au conseil de juridiction
un sujet qui peut tous nous rassembler
il perfectionne enfin la réforme des
juridictions disciplinaires des avocats
et des officiers publics ministériels ce
projet de loi n'oublie pas non plus
l'administration présidentielle et je
veux ici aujourd'hui saluer
solennellement l'ensemble des agents
pour les missions essentielles qu'ils
accomplissent dans des conditions
parfois difficiles ensuite des moyens
supplémentaires à louer cette
administration l'article 14 permet
d'apporter trois avancées
l'élargissement du Visier de la réserve
pénitentiaire la généralisation de
l'usage des caméras individuelles dans
les détentions
et les créations de surveillants
pénitentiaires adjoints le titre 5 est
consacré quant à lui à des réformes
procédurales il y a des adaptations du
régime de certaines professions du droit
ils ne traite pas de la réforme de la
procédure civile car celui-ci ne relève
pas de la loi pour autant la Commission
a souhaité exprimer son soutien au
développement d'une politique de
l'amiable en adoptant un amendement
important qui fixe dans le rapport
annexé les grandes en orientations de la
réforme sur deux autres sujets le niveau
de diplôme pour se présenter à l'examen
d'entrée du CRFPA et sur la
confidentialité des consultations des
juristes d'entreprise nous allons à
nouveau avoir un débat important en
séance
enfin le titre 6 est consacré aux
juridictions administratives et
financière il s'agit principalement de
mesures de simplification ou de
coordination liées aux transformations
récentes en conclusion nous avons un
texte ambitieux qui touche à presque
toutes les dimensions du droit et de la
justice pas forcément pour les
révolutionner mais pour apporter des
solutions concrètes attendues par les
professionnels et les usagers je
terminerai en évoquant la hausse
continue des moyens à laquelle s'engage
le gouvernement vous dire monsieur le
garde des sceaux que vous êtes le
ministre de la Justice qui aura permis
des augmentations du budget de la
justice sans précédent sous la 5ème
république vous dire cher Eric
Dupond-Moretti que vous aurez transformé
les états généraux de la justice en état
généreux de la justice je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Monsieur Erwan Balanant
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
République pour le projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de la Justice 2023-2027
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mes chers collègues
rapporteurs mesdames messieurs les
députés
la justice est la première vertu des
institutions sociales ces mots de John
rolls concentre à eux seuls l'essentiel
de ce que doit être notre justice une
institution garantissant la liberté et
l'équité l'examen de ce texte de loi
nous permet à mon sens de répondre à ses
exigences assis qu'aux attentes de nos
concitoyens qui veulent avoir une
confiance en une société libre équitable
et respectable avec un budget sans
précédent un plan d'action global
détaillé dans le rapport annexé et une
modernisation de la procédure pénale
respectivement adossée au Titre 1 et 2
dont j'ai l'honneur d'être apporteur
nous avançons vers une amélioration
concrète des conditions de travail et
des moyens alloués aux professionnels de
la justice
alors la trajectoire budgétaire engage
une augmentation inédite inédite de
21,3% des crédits sur la période 2023
2027 la création de 10 000 emplois
supplémentaires sur la période 2022-2027
dont 1500 magistrats et 1500 greffiers
alors il nous faudra évidemment être
vigilant sur le l'évolution du
recrutement les objectifs fixés sont
très ambitieux et il est impératif que
nous soyons rendez-vous pour renforcer
les juridictions et en ce sens
l'amendement proposé par la Commission
des finances prévoyant la remise d'un
rapport d'exécution tous les ans est
important pour que nous gardions notre
cap que nous gardions ce CAP
ce dernier est explicité dans le rapport
annexé véritable guide nous permettant
d'évoquer les sujets tels que la
politique de l'amiable ou encore
l'institutionnalisation de épaules
spécialisée en matière de lutte contre
les violences intrafamilales ces
avancées sont déjà particulièrement
réformatrices et à cela s'ajoute la
volonté du gouvernement et du garde des
sceaux de moderniser le code de
procédure pénale je salue cette volonté
d'allier modération l'amélioration des
moyens pardon à louer aux professionnels
de la justice à la simplification de
leur mission quotidienne avec
l'inflation législative le code de
procédure pénale est devenu
difficilement lisible et accessible il
doit être réécrit et je tiens à cet
égard à saluer la méthode prévue par le
gouvernement consacré par le Sénat dans
le rapport annexé consistant à associer
tous les groupes parlementaires tous les
groupes parlementaires et à identifier
les pistes de simplification sur
lesquelles nous pourrons nous prononcer
lors de l'examen du texte de
ratification et je tiens à rassurer nos
éventuels
la refonte par ordonnance sera faite à
droite constant aucune modification de
fond ne pourra être apportée dans ce
cadre ça serait d'ailleurs
inconstitutionnel je souhaite mettre en
avant quelques avancées importantes au
titre d'eux notamment avec l'imposant
article 3 la commission apportée des
enrichissements substantiels à commencer
par le régime des perquisitions de nuit
en matière de crime contre les personnes
ces ajustements permettent de ne vous
proposer un cadre robuste plus encadré
que ce qui existe déjà aujourd'hui en
matière de flagrance pour la criminalité
organisée
de même le recours à la visioconférence
pour l'examen médical en garde de vue en
garde à vue a été enrichi pour inscrire
dans la loi dans le dur de la loi les
hypothèses d'exclusion je tiens aussi à
saluer le travail important
transpartisan effectué à l'initiative de
Madame yadan de Madame kerbidi de
Monsieur Gosselin et de votre rapporteur
pour faire avancer les droits des
témoins assistés et l'accès au dossier
de procédures sur ma proposition nous
avons également harmonisé les règles
d'audition d'un témoin non soupçonné et
prévu que le prélèvement d'empreinte
sans consentement en garde à vue soit
doit être fait en présence de l'avocat
il me paraît aussi indispensable de
prendre quelques instants pour évoquer
dès à présent le dispositif de
l'activation à distance qui a fait
l'objet d'importants débats en
commission et de quelques craintes je
comprends que cette disposition génère
des inquiétudes
je les avais partagé au départ car elle
nous confronte à des évolutions
technologiques qui peuvent effrayer je
pense que beaucoup relèvent plutôt du
fantasme et qu'au sein de cette
technicité nous devons garder raison
la technique de géolocalisation et la
technique spéciale de captation d'images
ou de son existent déjà dans notre droit
ce sont des outils précieux pour nous
enquêteurs nous ne touchons pas aux
conditions mais nous les encadrons et
nous permettons à un nouveau procédé
mieux maîtriser par nos enquêteurs pour
y avoir recours et moins dangereux pour
eux je crois que nous devons garder cela
à l'esprit on en reparlera durant les
débats vous inquiétudes ont permis
d'enrichir le texte de nouvelles
garanties notamment bénéfice des
professions protégées par un secret
professionnel nous avons par ailleurs
clarifié la stricte interdiction de la
transcription des échanges avec un voca
un avocat et un journaliste et également
de toutes les changes qui seraient capté
par un appareil activé à distance il
apparaît que celui-ci se trouvait dans
le milieu dans le lieu pardon lié à
l'activité d'un avocat journaliste
médecin notaire huissier ou magistrat
les jeux conclurai président
et seront l'occasion de réaliser je
l'espère de nouvelles avancées de
nombreux amendements de la MA jorité de
l'opposition font d'ailleurs l'objet
d'un rapporteur
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Pradal
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
République pour le projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de la Justice 2023-2027
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois messieurs les
rapporteurs et Madame la rapporteur pour
avis chers collègues permettez-moi au
préalable et cela n'est pas son lien
avec le projet de loi sur la justice qui
nous réunit aujourd'hui de rendre
hommage aux forces de l'ordre police
nationale gendarmerie police municipale
aux sapeurs-pompiers et à tous ceux qui
font face avec courage et détermination
aux émeutes urbaines qui ont secoué
notre pays ces derniers jours ils font
preuve d'un professionnelalisme
exemplaire pour protéger les citoyens et
préserver la paix sociale leur
engagement et leurs deux vousments
méritent notre soutien
[Applaudissements]
ce même soutien nous devons l'exprimer à
l'institution judiciaire qui constitue
ainsi que le rappel l'exposé des motifs
du projet de loi dès la première phrase
le socle de notre pacte social c'est
tout l'intérêt de ce texte qui donne à
la justice les moyens budgétaires et
humains dont elle a besoin pour répondre
aux attentes de nos concitoyens ce texte
vous doit beaucoup monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie ainsi que vos services
pour le travail accompli ensemble ces
dernières semaines
mes travaux de rapporteur aux côtés du
rapporteur général chanté relié de nos
collègues Erwan Balan et Didier Paris
pour la loi organique emporté sur la
justice commerciale et sociale une
justice qui vit en première instance
grâce à l'engagement sur le terrain de
milliers de juge consulaires et
conseillers prud'hommes cet engagement
désintéressé doit être reconnu et
l'action des juges non professionnels
dans leur ensemble doit être salué
les tribunaux de commerce et les
conseils de prud'hommes sont des piliers
essentiels de notre système judiciaire
qui ont fait leurs preuves et auxquelles
nos concitoyens salariés et entreprises
sont attachées
le projet de loi pose les fondations
d'une justice économique avec un
élargissement expérimental des
compétences du tribunal de commerce ils
prévoient la mise en place sur le
territoire de 9 à 12 tribunaux des
activités économiques les Tae ainsi que
le versement par le demandeur d'une
contribution pour la justice économique
lors de l'introduction de l'instance
devant le Tae pour participer au
financement du service public de la
justice la Commission a adopté ses
dispositions avec quelques modifications
portant tant sur la composition que sur
les compétences du TL sur la composition
la Commission a fait le choix de ne pas
réintroduire la présence du magistrat
professionnel par le Sénat nous avons
pris acte des réserves à exprimées tant
par les suspensulaires que par les
magistrats professionnels sur cette
question
sur les compétences la Commission est
revenue sur quelques extensions que le
Sénat est introduite dans le texte en
matière de baux commerciaux et surtout
en matière de procédure collective pour
les professions réglementées du droit
nous aurons le débat en séance sur le
sujet des agriculteurs je considère pour
ma part que le secteur agricole a toute
sa place dans la construction d'une
justice économique en France à condition
que les agriculteurs soient représentés
dans la composition de la juridiction je
présenterai un amendement dans ce sens
nous aurons également le débat
concernant les associations je suis
plutôt réservé sur l'idée d'attraire
toutes les associations devant le Tae
pour traiter leurs difficultés
économiques de mon point de vue il faut
distinguer celles qui ont des activités
économiques de celles qui n'en ont pas
là encore le débat en séance sera très
utile pour fixer le juste périmètre du
tel
la commission également adoptée un
amendement dont je partage de la
paternité avec Philippe Gosselin qui
exonère toutes les entreprises de moins
de 250 salariés de la contribution pour
la justice économique je vous proposerai
en séance un amendement qui étant un peu
plus sécable exonération en visant
toutes les personnes physiques et
morales de moins de 250 salariés et pas
seulement les entreprises
j'en viens pour conclure au statut des
magistrats non professionnels cette
réforme de la justice apporte des
adaptations bienvenue pour harmoniser
les statues des juges consulaires et des
conseillers prud'hommes notamment
s'agissant du régime des sanctions des
déclarations d'atterris ou de leur
formation initiale le texte prévoit un
alignement de l'âge maximal pour exercer
les fonctions de conseiller prud'hommes
sur ce lit fixé pour les juges
consulaires il limite à 5 le nombre de
mandats consécutifs qu'un conseiller
prud'hommes peut exercer dans la même
juridiction pour éviter une application
trop abrupte de cette mesure je
proposerai un amendement vu de différer
l'entrée en vigueur jusqu'au prochain
renouvellement général des conseillers
prud'hommes prévus fin 2025 cette
souplesse permettra aux organisations
syndicales tant d'employeur que de
salariés de s'adapter et de préparer
cette transition
enfin mon initiative je signale que la
Commission adoptait un amendement qui
allonge de deux à six mois le délai de
dépôt des déclarations d'intérêt des
conseillers prud'hommes pour rendre
cette disposition applicables et
efficace comme vous le voyez monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
commission approuvé et renforcer les
grandes orientations du projet de loi
concernant la justice commerciale et
sociale je suis donc confiant sur le
fait que notre assemblée adoptera ces
différentes dispositions avec les
quelques ajustements évoqués je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Didier Paris se
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation de
l'administration générale de la
République pour le projet de loi
organique relative à l'ouverture la
modernisation et la responsabilité du
corps judiciaire
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs
collègues notre époque est tristement
marquée par une défiance généralisée à
l'égard de nos institutions une remise
en cause de l'état droit et de l'État
républicain qui va même jusqu'à être
dangereusement terroriste
terrorisée ça pourrait se dire
théoriser et mise en pratique par une
partie de la classe politique elle-même
la justice rendue au nom du peuple
français ni fait malheureusement pas
exception mais face au défi aux
incertitudes qui passent sur elles sont
statut tient en grande partie dans sa
capacité à s'adapter d'une certaine
façon à se remettre en cause et à
dialoguer selon des règles propres avec
la société et les pouvoirs publics
cet esprit et sans compromettre son
indépendance et son impartialité qu'elle
pourra assurer la mission essentielle
qui est la sienne
l'injonction est d'autant plus
impérative que l'attente de justice
reste paradoxalement toujours aussi fort
de la part de nos concitoyens et c'est
donc à ce défi majeur pour notre
démocratie que c'est appelé depuis
plusieurs années déjà notre majorité et
le gouvernement il est parti d'une
volonté forte et décisive du président
de la République a pris la forme des
états généraux de la justice suivi d'un
plan d'action particulièrement ambitieux
du ministre de la Justice
Eric Dupont-Moretti la traduction s'en
trouve en partie dans les deux textes
que nous abordons aujourd'hui en clair
nous poursuivons le patient et
indispensable travail de restauration de
notre justice exactement comme nous nous
étions engagés nous attendons de tous
les bancs de cette hémicycle un
consensus autour des efforts budgétaires
sont précédents sur les perspectives
hors normes de recrutement les
évolutions réglementaires annoncées en
particulier monsieur ministre vous
l'avez indiqué celle de la réforme
fondamentale de la médiation en matière
civile ainsi bien sûr qu'il y aura des
concent et l'amélioration du dialogue de
gestion que vous préconisez mais ces
changements de paradigme ne seront
réellement complets que s'ils sont
portés par de nouvelles transformations
du corps judiciaire recruter en quelques
années 1500 magistrats de plus c'est
nécessairement continué à faciliter
l'accès des professionnels rendre les
carrières plus attractives assouplir
encore le lien entre les grades et les
fonctions mieux évaluer le rôle
essentiel des magistrats en matière de
gestion et de ressources humaines
reconstruire les bases solides du
dialogue social ce sont quelques-uns des
fondamentaux du texte auquel les
magistrats veulent croire ne nous y
trompons pas la modification de la loi
organique il faut reconnaître un peu
technique qui fixe leur statut n'a pas
été opéré à cette ampleur depuis plus de
20 ans il s'agit rien de moins que
changer en profondeur les règles de
structuration ou d'accès au corps tout
en lui assurant une forte garantie
d'indépendance et de stabilité
si rajoute la nécessité d'entendre les
demandes exprimées au cours des états
généraux de la justice tout autant que
de suivre les suggestions du Conseil
supérieur de la mestrature au regard de
l'affaiblissement de la responsabilité
des magistrats c'est ainsi que la loi
organique prévoit une reformulation du
serment les laboration d'une
chardonontologie une plus grande
diversification des chaînes des
sanctions ainsi que l'amélioration très
sensible du droit de plainte des
justiciables plus d'efficacité plus de
transparence pour plus de confiance tout
en maintenant un système suffisamment
équilibré pour ne pas perturber
l'activité des magistrats ou à tenter
d'une quelconque manière que ce soit
alors indépendance le Sénat saisit en
première lecture à opérer un travail de
fond auquel il faut à l'évidence rendre
hommage
mais notre commission des lois en lien
avec le gouvernement n'a pas été en
reste et nous avons pu rectifier ou
améliorer de nombreux dispositifs
essentiels à mes yeux il faut le
reconnaître de manière là encore assez
consensuelle c'est le cas de
l'encadrement de la liberté syndicale
des magistrats que le Sénat voulait lier
à un critère d'impartialité qui le
vidait de son sens pour beaucoup d'entre
nous c'est aussi un restauration d'un
certain nombre d'équilibre pour assurer
une meilleure garantie d'indépendance du
corps en prévoyant notamment la présence
majoritaire des magistrats dans les
nombreux jurys ou collège et de
nombreuses autres dispositifs il s'est
aussi assis agit de maintenir le rôle
propre du ministre de la Justice en
particulier dans le schéma nouveau de
responsabilité des magistrats l'ensemble
de ces raisons me donne la conviction
que les évolutions à la fois internes
externes du corps judiciaire contenu
dans cette loi organique répondent
parfaitement aux exigences de qualité et
d'efficacité acité de notre justice et
symbris sans aucun doute dans le large
plan d'action mis en oeuvre par Eric
Dupont-Moretti des vidanges notre groupe
il sera pleinement favorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la parole est à Monsieur Sacha Oullier
président de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
République
monsieur le président
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux mais celui-là rapporteur
chers collègues nous avons aujourd'hui
une grande responsabilité et nous ne
serons nous dérobés face à celle-ci car
la loi de programmation de la justice
c'est tout simplement le rétablissement
l'autorité judiciaire en lui donnant
durablement un budget digne de ce nom et
je veux saluer en préambule les efforts
accomplis d'abord par à vos
prédécesseurs monsieur le garde des
sceaux Madame Christiane Taubira madame
monsieur Jean-Jacques urboise et surtout
et surtout madame Nicole Belloubet qui
ont leur temps ont fait leur possible
et aujourd'hui l'effort est sans
précédent il est inégalé et il vient
après 3 augmentations successives de
budget de la Chancellerie 8% chaque
année depuis 2020 avec 7 milliards et
demi d'euros sur la période courant de
2022 à 2027 c'est tout simplement un
sixième budget pour la justice en un
quinquennat plus personne désormais ne
pourra parler de clochardisation de la
justice car dans cette loi il y a
beaucoup de plus et selon une expression
consacrée le plus c'est différent du
moins cette fois c'est aussi la
démonstration que pour une fois le mieux
n'est pas l'ennemi du bien et ce qu'il
faut saluer c'est d'abord la méthode
puisque il le texte repose également sur
la plus grande étude d'impact jamais
réalisée les états généraux de la
justice consultation majeur qui a réuni
tous les acteurs des métiers du droit
jusqu'aux justiciables lui-même et je
remarque que sur cette question je les
ai entendu jusqu'à présent aucune
critique désormais il est primordial de
traduire ses orientations dans un texte
législatif et nous y sommes je le redis
appelle chacun d'entre nous à ne pas se
dérober dans la responsabilité qui est
la sienne c'est à dire voter ses projets
de loi car au fond de quoi s'agit-il
rendre la procédure pénale plus efficace
rendre la réponse pénale également plus
efficace accélérée drastiquement les
délais de la justice civile moderniser
la justice commerciale mieux reconnaître
la juridiction administrative et les
chiffres vous les connaissez mais il
mérite d'être rabâché à l'envie car non
déplaise à certains nous en sommes
extrêmement fiers 10
000 emplois supplémentaires d'ici 2027
1500 magistrats en plus 1500 greffiers
en plus des augmentations salariales des
changements de grille indiciaire y
compris pour les agents de la
pénitentiaire que je salue
quoi qu'on en dise nous avons travaillé
et dans la commission nous avons
travaillé également pour que toutes les
voies de recrutement soit utilisées y
compris celles des doctorants ces
personnels supplémentaires ils viendront
renforcer les réformes déjà entreprises
par notre majorité il recrutement en
nombre significatif de futurs attachés
de justice sera déterminant pour
structurer les équipes juridictionnelles
qui viendront renforcer notamment les
futurs pôles spécialisés de lutte contre
les violences intrafamiliales là encore
nous mettons des moyens à la hauteur de
nos ambitions les crédits
supplémentaires seront aussi affectées à
la transformation numérique du ministère
vous savez qu'il y a fort à faire la
crise du covid la révélé simplifier la
procédure pénale c'est aussi une
ambition et ce ne sont pas que des mots
le texte prévoit une réforme à droite
constant à droite constant d'une répète
pour ceux qui ont du mal à entendre et
qui instrumentalise tout ce qui peut
l'être au fin de encore une fois de se
dérober face à leur responsabilité je le
redis je n'ai pas besoin de m'étendre
face au constat partagé par tous le code
de procédure pénal c'est un code
illisible des articles inintégriques
inintelligible regorgeant d'incohérence
par l'effet de plusieurs renvois je vous
épargne la litanie à ce sujet mais je me
rejoins mais je me réjouis de la
procédure qui a été retenue c'est à dire
un comité parlementaire pour suivre les
travaux une démarche qui avait fait le
succès du code de justice pénale des
mineurs et qui a été ainsi renouvelé
j'en appelle aussi la responsabilité des
parlementaires pour ce qui concerne la
prison 15000 places construites en 10
ans c'est un impératif de salubrité
publique c'est une exigence d'ordre
public nous ne céderons à ce titre ni à
l'assurance chère sécuritaire de ceux
qui veulent toujours plus de place sans
jamais donner le moindre permis de
construire nous savons non plus pas à la
béatitude et à l'hypocrisie de ceux qui
refusent de voir les efforts faits quant
à l'aménagement des peines ou à
encore le contrat conclu récemment
j'avance rapidement pour la nouvelle
place qui a été offerte à la justice
commerciale et si nous avons entendu les
inquiétudes des juges conçus d'air
consulaires je dis également qu'une
réflexion doit être engagée par la
Conférence des Présidents sur le la
procédure de référer et les procédures à
jujigny j'évoque également la procédure
civile qui fait l'objet de délai créer
et dont nous débattrons pas même s'il y
aurait des tentadir je veux dire encore
un mot sur les juridictions
administratives et le fait que au
travers quelques amendements notamment
la prestation de serment des magistrats
administratives nous souhaitions
reconnaître le titre de juge de plaine
office au juge administratif qui l'a
démontré lors de la crise covid vous le
voyez la tâche qui nous attend désormais
est importante encore une fois c'est la
responsabilité qui préside je l'ai
suffisamment répété la responsabilité
elle est entre vos mains elle est entre
nos mains pour enfin doter la justice de
moyens dont elle a besoin et c'est ce
que nous avons de faire ici et
maintenant
merci monsieur le président
j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde panot et
des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nupet une motion de rejet
préalable déposée en application de
l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement sur
le projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de la Justice
2023 2027 la parole est à Monsieur Hugo
bernalicis
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues
sans justice pas de paix
la justice est un service public hors
norme hors du commun parce qu'il est
essentiel au Bien Vivre ensemble parce
qu'elle est la justice et le recours
ultime le point d'aboutissement de tous
les autres services publics lorsque
ceux-ci n'ont plus accomplir leur
mission c'est-à-dire résoudre les
conflits ou protéger les citoyens
ultime recours des couples qui se
séparent des familles qui se disputent
de la jeunesse en danger ou délinquant
des enfants abusés des femmes violentées
des salariés abusivement licenciés des
victimes de voleurs d'escrocs d'assassin
des victimes de scandale sanitaires de
catastrophes ou terrorisme la justice
est saisie au final de tous les drames
petits ou grand vécus par les individus
de la société c'est pourquoi nous
attachons toujours une extrême
importance au texte qui ont très à la
justice et j'ajouterai qu'il n'y a pas
d'ordre public possible sans justice
sociale vous savez que ce terme de
justice est souvent évoqué dans le pays
comme étant une aspiration légitime
un peu de mémoire
j'ai envie de dire 50 perdues je vous ai
déjà toutes et tous entendu à cette même
tribune en 2018 sur le projet de loi de
programmation et d'orientation nous
expliquer qu'avec les moyens que vous
alliez débloqué la justice serait enfin
d'aplomb pour faire face aux grands
enjeux de notre société
que s'est-il passé
trois ans plus tard
les états généraux de la justice sont
lancés pour enfin réparer la justice je
pensais qu'elle était déjà moi j'avais
écouté poliment le garde des sceaux qui
nous avait dit tout le bien qu'il
pensait de sa propre politique je
finissais même par être convaincu et là
tribune des 3000 magistrats
suite au suicide d'une de leurs
collègues à Lille
et puis sans son suivi des tas de
mobilisation historique de la justice
donnant plutôt envie d'avoir une
politique humble d'essayer de faire au
mieux plutôt que de fanfaronner et
pétarader sur vos prétendus succès
alors regardons
budget historique
historique 7,5 milliards bon déjà c'est
moitié moins que Darmanin
est-ce que vous ferez moitié moins bien
je ne sais pas puisque au final pourquoi
faire c'est ça la question de fond
pourquoi faire
pour prolonger une justice de classe non
ce ne sera pas avec nous en tout cas
donc ces projets de loi d'orientation et
de programmation interroge par-delà leur
simple montant parce que vous
n'achèterez personne simplement avec de
l'argent
et quand on regarde le détail pas de ce
projet de loin parce qu'il n'y en a pas
vous ne serez pas où va l'argent on vous
donne vaguement des indices construire
des places de prison ça on avait bien
compris pour le reste ben écoutez on
repassera 1500 magistrats recrutés
comment on verra bien surtout avec des
passerelles pour les mettre où on verra
plus tard pour faire quoi
éventuellement ce qu'on aura mis dans ce
texte et encore on ne sait pas
exactement
je reprends un exemple un seul exemple
j'avais dit à cette tribune dans le
projet de loi 2018 2022 qu'il y avait un
élément qui a tiré mon attention sur
lequel j'étais extrêmement favorable
un milliard d'euros pour le numérique
promesse de Nicole Belloubet fête à
cette tribune j'avais dit bah c'est
toujours ça de pris au moins quand on
gagnera en 20002 ce qui n'a pas été le
cas malheureusement
au moins ce sera toujours ça te fait que
s'est-il passé en 2022 on n'a pas gagné
certes mais il est où le milliard pour
le numérique on en vient péniblement à
nous expliquer qu'une application
smartphone permet de faire une
simulation en ligne de l'aide
juridictionnelle déjà disponible depuis
plusieurs années sur service tirés
publiques.fr et disponible avec tous les
smartphones d'aujourd'hui c'est pas ça
l'enjeu de la justice est encore moins
du numérique alors j'ai vu qu'il fallait
donner son avis par le biais d'un bouton
je sais pas si j'ai actionné le bon pour
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas je vous
donnerai celui de mon groupe oui un
budget historique ça se questionne et ça
s'interroge pour savoir ce qu'on compte
en faire
d'abord sur la justice civile qui est
l'essentiel de l'activité
l'essentiel de notre justice est
consacré aussi les 70%
et qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans le texte des
promesses en annexe de faire des travaux
réglementaires on nous parle monsieur le
ministre gentiment nous dit ah bah
attendez je vous ai envoyé le décret moi
j'ai pas vu trace mais je doute je ne
doute pas plutôt qu'il nous arrive
finalement à un moment donné ou un autre
mais qui ne fait pas l'objet de débat
étrange d'ailleurs la césure c'est très
intéressant on pourrait débattre
tranquillement mais ce n'est pas de ça
dont on parle pareil sur le service
public des modes alternatifs des
différents et des litiges vous savez que
vous avez eu un gros débat sur le sujet
puisque c'était le cœur de la loi de
Nicole Belloubet 2018-2022 avec une
promesse que tout aille mieux dans le
pays encore une fois ce qui reste à
démontrer évidemment ou plutôt la
démonstration inverse ayant été faite on
cherche le bilan et on se dit finalement
que les états généraux de la justice
avaient vu juste en disant qu'il fallait
réinvestir ces modes alternatifs des
différents et des litiges mais pas pour
les rendre payants ni préalablement
obligatoire à la procédure et donc
payant avec des conciliateurs de justice
qui sont malheureusement inaccessibles
avec des délais beaucoup trop longs
faisant en sorte que quand vous avez un
litige avec la nouvelle procédure
finalement mais bout à bout tout ça vous
prend plus de temps pour le résoudre
moins de temps pour la justice au sens
justice judiciaire mais vous en tant que
judiciable plus de temps ah la belle
trouvaille la belle trouvaille la
gestion des flux et des stocks
finalement c'est ça qui est la boussole
et qui vous intéresse en petit comptable
d'essayer de fermer le robinet entrant
d'ouvrir le robinet sortant d'accélérer
la moulinette de tout ça avec des sucres
rapides nous a-t-on dit pour faire une
équipe autour du magistrat tout ça dans
la précipitation le covid ayant fait la
démonstration
une démonstration de plus d'une justice
à bout de souffle
alors on recrute des contractuels
d'abord pour trois mois puis la bataille
s'ensuit 6 mois puis la bataille
continue on se dit que c'est pas
possible de les garder que 6 mois
3 ans renouvelable une fois puis
maintenant les attacher de justice
mais il y a quelque chose qui cloche
là-dedans ça ressemble à dubiricolage
par construction alors tant mieux pour
ceux qui sortent un peu de la précarité
mais regardons la vision d'ensemble y
a-t-il vraiment un consensus et un
accord sur ce qu'on attend du magistrat
comme étant demain manager d'attacher de
justice qui eux prépareront les
décisions alors que jusqu'à présent
c'est le magistrat qui doit rendre
lui-même sa décision et une équipe ça
aurait pu être une équipe deux
magistrats plutôt qu'une équipe autour
du magistrat voilà une autre perspective
qu'on aurait pu tracer et s'il avait
fallu des gens pour entourer le
magistrat
il y a des personnes qui s'appellent les
greffières et les greffiers ils ont une
robe
avec vous savez un rabat
il ressemble un peu aux autres mais
c'est pas les mêmes que les autres
et d'ailleurs
ils sont en lutte en ce moment vous avez
dit il y a une justice mobilisée
monsieur le ministre vous avez raison
belle allusion à la mobilisation des
greffiers et des greffiers
parce que il y a un poste de greffier
qui s'appelle assistant du magistrat
assistant du magistrat mais ça ressemble
bizarrement à attacher de justice et que
croyez-vous qu'il se passe dans les
juridictions sur les greffiers
assistants du magistrat on leur dit si
vous voulez continuer à faire assistant
du magistrat faudra devenir attaché de
justice voilà ce qu'on dit au greffier
qui se battent depuis des années pour
davantage de reconnaissance pour avoir
un parcours à l'intérieur du ministère
pour évoluer pour progresser pour être
justement autour du magistrat mais pas à
sa place parce que le greffier il
authentifie la procédure il est garants
de la procédure et il est indépendant
aussi du magistrat c'est ça qui permet
de faire tourner l'organisation
judiciaire correctement alors monsieur
le ministre pour attirer votre attention
ils ont un peu détourné une chanson
alors vous m'excuserez je chante très
mal
mais je suis sûr que vous allez
reconnaître
alors je vous dis juste de coupler parce
que sinon c'est ça pourra trop de temps
ça fait au dit moi
regarde-moi je ne sais plus comment
aimer mon boulot de greffier parle-moi
je ne sais plus pourquoi
continuer monsieur le député se sont
exprimés devant les tribunaux et partout
en France pour attirer l'attention du
ministre
parce que ils ont l'impression d'être
les grands oubliés de cet enchaînement
de bricolage là on nous avait promis une
grande réflexion
et puis sur la planification on
repassera à Lille par exemple
un nouveau projet de tribunal était dans
les cartons
et ben vous savez quoi ils ont cherché
un deuxième bâtiment où mettre les gens
et comme là il y a des annonces qui sont
faites on cherche un troisième bâtiment
pour mettre les gens en plus qu'on va
recruter
la belle anticipation la belle
organisation voilà pourquoi j'explique
qu'il y a 50 gâchis parce qu'il y avait
des gens qui alerté à cette tribune ici
il y a déjà 5 ans il est même méprisant
en face de nous nous expliquer que c'est
bon il savait gérer tout allait bien et
tout allait aller mieux
[Applaudissements]
donc ce sera sans nous
pour cette projet pour ce projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation car
cela ne va pas dans la bonne direction
bien qu'il y ait quelques moyens
supplémentaires personne ne peut en
disconvenir mais justement
de plus près il y a l'aspirateur géant
de la prison qui aspire tous les crédits
ce qui fait qu'il reste pas beaucoup
pour les autres et c'est là une
signature politique construire des
places de prison mettre des gens dans
les places de prison tenir la société
comme aller maintenir votre ordre public
qui est là sans justice sociale et ça je
dois le dire c'est une véritable
signature vous nourrissez l'effet
cliquez y compris en matière de
procédure
maintenant on va pouvoir faire des
perquisitions de nuit maintenant on va
pouvoir prendre possession de n'importe
quel objet connecté pour pouvoir vous
écouter ou vous voir
maintenant
on pourra aller beaucoup plus vite pour
un carré et je veux faire un petit point
sur l'administration pénitentiaire
2400 personnes sur des matelas au sol
j'interpelle les collègues macronistes
qui nous avaient fait la promesse avec
la loi 2018-2022 de supprimer les
courtes peines de diminuer le nombre
d'incarcération et que par un effet de
vasque communiquant en construisant des
places et en incarcérant moins et moins
de courtepennes on allait finalement
arriver à l'enseignement individuel vous
nous avez fait voter au détour d'un
projet de loi de finances
le prolongation du moratoire sur
l'enseignement individuel jusque 2027
faisant à nouveau la promesse qu'avec
votre politique on va y arriver mais
c'est du grand n'importe quoi
ne serait-ce que imaginons que le pays
s'embrasse imaginons
que vous soyez contraint d'interpeller
d'incarérer en masse voilà qui poserait
des problèmes par de la Ligue 2400
matelas au sol
regardez comment à Gradignan s'il vous
plaît les chefs d'établissement
pénitentiaire en vient à dire STOP écrou
croyez-vous que l'on puisse faire un
travail correct en détention qui que
l'on soit surveillant tous les
accompagnements associatifs les
conseillers pénitentiaires d'insertion
de probation avec une surpopulation
comme celle-là non on ne peut pas faire
un travail sérieux alors il faut un
mécanisme de régulation carcérale
demandée par les États généraux de la
justice ça aurait été le cœur de votre
réflexion notamment en matière
d'administration pénitentiaire
mais non les États généraux n'auront pas
suffi puisque eux ont proposé un
mécanisme de régulation carcérale alors
j'espère que chacun devant ses
responsabilités
votre a les amendements qui vont dans
cette direction pour un véritable
mécanisme de régulation carcérale et ça
ne vous empêchera pas vous autres de
droite de dire à il nous manque des
places de prison il faut incarcéré
davantage d'ailleurs vous aurez des
chiffres de combien de personnes on a
libéré par anticipation et d'ailleurs
vous avez vous-même collègue de droite
votez le précédent texte justice
confiance qui prévoyait la libération
sous contrainte automatique à 3 mois de
la fin de peine sans contenu sans rien
il vous reste moins de trois mois
allez-y sortez et là un mécanisme de
régulation carcérale avec un juge
d'application des peines qui
interviendrait avec une logique ça vous
n'en voulez pas mais enfin réfléchissez
un instant allez jusqu'au bout de vos
convictions
qu'allez-vous faire quand il y aura les
4000 matelas au sol et que les prisons
s'embraseront elles-mêmes qu'allez-vous
faire
soyez responsables soyez responsables
je terminerai
je terminerai en vous disant que
finalement
le sens
de ce projet de loi est assez clair et
symptomatique le mieux public management
appliqué comme d'habitude avec
pointillisme pour s'assurer une gestion
des stocks optimale peu importe que va
devenir le dossier peu importe que sont
les gens derrière le dossier l'important
c'est que les dossiers avancent et
accélère vous confondez comme d'habitude
vitesse et précipitations quand
j'entends célérité dans votre bouche je
me dis juste ah justice d'abattage et
quand on voit comment fonctionne les
comparutions immédiates alors oui il y a
fort à faire pour le ministère de la
justice mais pas dans cette direction et
si vous aviez été honnête vous auriez
publié le besoin en nombre de magistrats
juridictions par juridiction et ça ça
aurait été une feuille de route qu'on
aurait pu s'assigner collectivement
et sinon c'est 10000 voilà 1500
magistrats débrouillez-vous pour les
affecter les sénateurs ont essayé de
mettre 1800 greffiers à la place de 1500
péniblement même ça c'est de trop on est
revenu à 1500 finalement ce sera sans
nous voilà pourquoi nous faisons une
motion de rejet préalable
je vous remercie
et je vous informe que sur le vote de la
motion de rejet je suis saisie par le
groupe Renaissance par le groupe la
France insoumise d'une demande de
scrutin public le scrutin est annoncé
la parole avant les explications de vote
est au rapporteur terrier
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues Hugo bernalicis on vous a
écouté pendant plus de 15 minutes et je
crois qu'on a
pu entendre un nouvel exemple de la
politique lamentable que vous venez de
la terre brûlée en réalité vous ne
préoccupez pas du fond du texte le
président parle de France incendiaire
mais je crois que je partage avec lui
cet avis et pourtant je trouve que c'est
compliqué au stade de nos explications
qu'on est cette discussion au fond je
pense que ce que vous regrettez au fond
de vous je pense que vous le regrettez
sincèrement c'est que depuis 2017 vous
n'ayez pas voté des budgets
d'augmentation historique pour la
justice plus 54 % d'augmentation des
budgets de la justice depuis 2017 c'est
le relèvement historique du service
public de la justice à travers le vote
de ces deux budgets sous ces
demandatures et qu'est-ce que va faire
la France insoumise elle va s'opposer à
vote de ses budgets alors quand on vous
entend venir dire par un revers par un
revers de bain que vous allez vous
opposer à la création de 10000 postes de
10 000 postes qui vont venir intégrer
notre notre service de la justice quand
vous venez dire au fond avec beaucoup de
mépris que le recrutement de ces
attachés de justice au fond serait comme
vous l'avez dit des sous magistrats
quand elle était il ne viendrait
apporter qu'il viendrait apporter
absolument aucune aide aucune aide à la
prise de décision de nos magistrats je
pense que vous aurez pu vous aurez pu
peut-être regarder interroger peut-être
vos présidents de juridiction qui vous
auront dit que c'est magistrats que ces
attachés de justice en complément du
travail dégriffé sont excessivement
importants pour le bon déroulement déjà
la justice quand et si vous aviez pu
participer peut-être à nos débats il y a
nos auditions dans le cadre de ce projet
de loi vous auriez entendu l'École
nationale de la magistrature vous auriez
entendu l'École nationale des grèves
venir vous dire qu'il est possible
demain de former 1500 magistrats qu'il
est possible de former demain en 5 ans
1500 greffiers que tout cela se fait
grâce à l'augmentation des moyens
substantiels de la justice donc venir
tout et aujourd'hui
balayer d'un revers de main je crois que
évidemment c'est pas la hauteur et donc
encore une fois la France insoumise je
crois par cette notion de rejet démontre
encore une fois qu'elle n'est pas à la
hauteur de l'engagement attendu par nos
concitoyens encore une fois de
l'augmentation substantielle des budgets
dont tu as besoin pour son
fonctionnement notre justice
et vous avez trouvé un truc qui vous
chagrine un truc sur le numérique un
truc sur l'assistant de justice vous
direz aussi que vous avez vu un truc
bizarre sur les techniques spéciales
d'enquête parce que ce n'est pas un
enjeu pour vous de lutter contre le
crime organiser et le terrorisme alors
soyez cohérent vous nous demandez de
voter vos amendements mais vous ne
demandez également de rejeter ce texte
soyez cohérent la preuve par l'exemple
aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas un enjeu
pour vous la justice aujourd'hui que
vous ne vous a intéressé pas aux enjeux
de notre pays que ce n'est pas un enjeu
suffisamment sérieux la justice pour
sortir de votre posture habituelle
encore une fois vous nous démontrer ici
que pour VOUS ICI c'est un jeu
je vous remercie
et je vous demanderai s'il vous plaît
chers collègues un petit peu d'attention
merci de bien vouloir écouter les
orateurs vous avez pris la parole
pendant 15 minutes sur la motion de
rejet merci d'écouter les explications
de vote en retour s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît c'est pénible vraiment
alors non je vous assure non non
absolument pas alors la parole alors je
vous demande calme un petit peu de calme
un peu de calme bon la parole est au
rassemblement national monsieur
Jean-Philippe Tanguy merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur ministre messieurs
les rapporteurs chers collègues ce
projet de loi ne mérite ni exet
d'honneur ni l'indemnité dont Monsieur
benalicis prétend la fumer constatant
les nième motion de rejet préalable
déposé par la France insoumise me sont
revenus les mots d'Oscar Wilde la
caricature et l'hommage que la
médiocrité pays au génie quel caricature
en effet est devenu la nupesse face au
génie de la Cinquième République vous
vous paraît des oripeaux de la Première
République mortonnée ensanglanté par le
comité salut public mais c'est pour
mieux refuser tout débat en raison car
pour débattre en raison chers collègues
il faut respecter les institutions vous
les piétiner pour débattre en raison
il faut respecter ses collègues et ses
adversaires vous les méprisez voir vous
les haïssez pourquoi en vrai
discuteriez-vous des moyens de la
justice vous les insoumis vous la nuit
pèse qui avait des trouver des méthodes
si indignes pour pour déshonorer cette
justice vous avez humilié des années de
combat de lutte pour contrôler violences
faites aux femmes avec vos comités de
copinage et de règlement de compte en
direct à la télévision mais pour qui
vous prenez vous pourquoi que votre
groupe suscule peuvent manier le glaive
de la justice pire encore à quoi bon
avoir une justice républicaine quand
messieurs Mélenchon monsieur Guiraud ou
monsieur Boyard c'est riche en minosera
d'amande et hack de carnaval juste des
enfers gauchistes prêts à salir tous les
jours l'honneur des forces de l'ordre
sur la base d'une seule vidéo et
d'appeler aux émeutes appelés aux
émeutes avant de pleurnicher pleurnicher
évidemment sur les conséquences de leur
acte pour qui vous peut pour qui vous
prenez-vous pour croire que vos immenses
égaux sur pattes n'ont d'autre devoirs
que d'appeler au respect de la
République votre zadisme parlementaires
chers collègues est un cocktail
monocoque qui explosera entre vos mains
de petits bourgeois vous vous rêvez
hériter de la Révolution vous n'êtes au
mieux que des rostands de Mai 68 3
manque de vue sur Tik Tok pour finir
comme vous comme nous l'avons commencé
avec
Oscar Wilde prenez garde collègue à
soumis au portrait de votre mandat elle
est défigurée par votre haine de la
France je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Elisa Martin pour
le groupe la France insoumise merci
madame la Présidente
qui dit loi de programmation dit
engagement financier et précis de ce
point de vue le compte n'y est pas qui
dit loi d'orientation dit stratégie
stratégie pour une justice forte
républicaine équitable si nous nous
réjouissons évidemment des embauches
pour les personnels de justice et
particulièrement pour les magistrats
cette embauche n'est pas suffisante pour
définir une stratégie pour la justice
pour notre beau pays
ainsi appeler quand nous appelons à la
déflation à la régulation carcérale qui
est absolument nécessaire monsieur le
garde des sceaux vous nous répondez
15000 places de prison qui seront
remplies évidemment au fur et à mesure
où elles seront construites à la
rectitude de la justice vous opposez
comparution immédiate et sévérités
jusqu'au mépris de la plus élémentaire
des plus élémentaires droits accordés la
défense sans même considérer le
caractère réparateur j'ose le dire le
sens de la peine enfin et c'est
désormais habituel de la part d'un
gouvernement de ce gouvernement qui tout
simplement a peur du peuple vous
apportez votre pierre à l'édifice à la
société de surveillance généralisée par
la généralisation la banalisation je
sais pas on verra bien comment on dit
des perquisitions de nuit mais aussi
surtout par l'activation à distance de
tout objet connecté et ce au mépris de
non plus basiques liberté fondamentale
que sont en particulier la vie privée
ainsi nous vous appelons monsieur le
garde des sceaux à revoir votre copie et
à remballer et nous rejetons donc ce
projet de loi
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Philippe Gosselin pour le
groupe la républicain merci Madame la
provisante et nous voilà une Xième fois
avec une XIème motion de rejet on vous a
connu meilleur et pas simplement en
chantant chers collègues bernalicis ça
tombait un peu à plat et sur un sujet
aussi grave que la justice qui est
rendue au nom du peuple français on
pouvait attendre une autre tonalité à
force d'user et d'abuser de vos motions
de rejet voulait banaliser un peu à
l'image finalement de votre groupe et on
aimerait bien avoir des sens de
responsabilité plus aiguisées dans des
moments où l'ensemble du pays est sous
pression plutôt que d'avoir des
insoumissions à géométrie variable vous
qui est donnez facilement des leçons
vous feriez mieux de voir ce qu'il en
est de cette justice qui est aujourd'hui
encore pour une part clochardisée alors
le projet
n'est pas la panacée c'est évident nous
y reviendrons dans quelques minutes mais
nous nous souhaitons au républicains que
le débat puisse se poursuivre nous le
devons à nos concitoyens nous le devons
au victimes nous le devons tout
simplement à la justice parce qu'elle
est un élément indispensable de notre
démocratie et on ne peut pas sans cesse
différer des débats ce que vous
souhaitez faire car en réalité ce qui
fait votre miel c'est le bazar le fourbi
la bordalisation tout le monde l'a bien
compris
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Blandine brocard
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues si je devais résumer ici
en deux mots les projets de loi que nous
allons examiner je dirais ceci volonté
politique volonté politique depuis 6 ans
pour mettre fin à plusieurs décennies
d'abandon politique de notre système
judiciaire qui se retrouve dans un état
de délabrement insupportable les
Français doutent de notre justice et les
magistrats peines à exercer correctement
leur mission et si je devais collègue de
là et les filles résumé votre méthode
pour ce texte pour les précédents bref
votre SAP systématique du fonctionnement
de nos institutions et bien je dirais
énième renoncement politique
la seule manifestation de votre
opposition se résume une nouvelle fois à
bâillonner notre assemblée et votre
blabla vide on te méprisant et
irresponsable monsieur bernabicis on est
le terrible révélateur
quelle représentant de la nation peut en
conscience s'opposer à 10 milliards
d'euros au bénéfice de la justice
qu'elle représentant de la nation peut
en conscience refuser le recrutement
massif de 10000 personnes quelle
représentant de la nation peut refuser
en toute conscience la revalorisation
statutaire et salariale de nombre de
métiers quelle représentant de la nation
peut en toute conscience s'opposer à la
création de nouveaux postes de personnel
pénitentiaire mais pire encore alors que
notre pays subit ces dernières heures de
violent troubles et bien qu'elle
représentant de la nation peut décemment
choisir sur ce texte une telle motion je
m'interroge et je suis loin d'être la
seule il y a une certitude en revanche
nous concernant nous considérons que ce
texte est un signal fort envoyé à la
justice que c'est attendu de nos
concitoyens et de ceux qui travaillent
pour la justice et pour toutes ces
raisons il n'est pas question de refuser
un tête débat c'est pourquoi nous
voterons évidemment contre cette motion
de rejet pour la justice pour les
Français
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame Cécile intermeyer
pour le groupe socialiste merci merci
madame la Présidente en fait la Bossion
de rejet c'est un outil qui existe et
qui est à la disposition des députés et
je pense que ce n'est pas faire offense
que de d'utiliser cette notion de rejet
d'ailleurs vos
vous avez supprimé la motion de renvoi
qui était une motion intelligente qui
permettait de dire que le texte n'était
pas suffisamment abouti et finalement
vous n'offrez plus la possibilité d'une
motion de rejet qui à notre sens
invisibilise finalement cette procédure
parce que elle est en recours trop
systématique nous semble-t-il c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas à
déposé de motion de rejet nous n'avons
pas déposé une notion de rejet parce que
nous considérons que ce texte comme l'a
dit d'ailleurs mon collègue Gosselin il
est attendu par la population il est
attendu par les professionnels et il est
attendu par le législateur qui à la
commission des lois a besoin de
légiférer et de débattre de ces
questions nous n'avons pas déposé une
motion de rejet au regard des crédits
massifs quand même qui sont mises en
place et dont il nous appartient à nous
de vérifier l'affectation ça sera
effectivement notre travail à nous tous
législateurs sur tous les bancs et nous
ne l'avons pas fait non plus ce travail
parce que nous de cette motion de rejet
parce que nous considérons que des fils
sont tirés à partir du le travail de
Christiane Taubira qui a été cité et je
le remercie par Sacha Ollier mais aussi
par Jean-Jacques Urvoas sur la nécessité
de remonter sur les budgets et puis les
États généraux c'est déjà la conférence
de consensus qui avait élaboré
Christiane tobira alors nous ne voterons
pas cette motion de rejet ou voterons
contre cette motion de rejet ne
serait-ce que parce que nous souhaitons
la clarté et parce que nous législateur
pour nous il est essentiel de débattre
et nous débattrons parce que il y a des
points de désaccord qui ont été évoqués
par la France insoumise qui mérite
effectivement ce débat notamment ceux
dont qui ont été évoqués par Hugo
bernalicis à la tribune et donc c'est la
raison aussi pour laquelle nous ne
voterons pas et nous voterons contre
cette mesure de rejet
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur henrielle Fondary pour le
groupe horizon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre monsieur
la rapporteur monsieur le Président de
la Commission chers collègues je vais
vous surprendre mais je suis d'accord
avec vous d'abord parce que avec vous
pour dire que pour la justice c'est un
service public qui a trop longtemps été
relayé au second plan d'accord avec vous
pour dire que nous manquons de personnel
de justice de personnel pénitentiaires
d'accord avec vous pour dire qu'il faut
revaloriser financièrement ces process
ces professions si essentielles alors
que faire votre réponse est la suivante
il nous faudrait donc même pas débattre
et donc encore moins adopter ce projet
de loi d'orientation et de programmation
qui vise à injecter plus de 10 milliards
d'euros dans cette institution en
souffrance il ne faudrait pas prévoir le
recrutement de 1500 magistrats et 2500
greffiers non il ne faudrait surtout pas
permettre au juge d'être épaulé par des
attaches de justice encore moins créer
un statut de surveillant pénitentiaire
adjoint quand on sait à quel point nos
prisons manquent de personnel
mais chers collègues et les filles les
Français sont pas dupe vos
contradictions se révèlent un peu plus
chaque jour vous voulez des milliers de
magistrats maintenant tout de suite et
reprochez ensuite l'insuffisance de leur
formation cette majorité s'est attelé
comme aucune autre à réhabiliter ce si
beau service public avec conviction et
pragmatiste nous opposerons donc à cette
notion de rejet insensée je vous
remercie
je n'ai pas d'autre demande
d'explication de vote alors nous allons
procéder au scrutin public merci de
regagner vos places scrutin public sur
la motion de rejet
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat du scrutin votant 121 exprimé
120 majorités 61 pour 23 contre 97
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté la
motion de rejet
et nous en venons donc à la discussion
générale sur ce texte
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Félix
Aquaviva pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoires
monsieur le député
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le rapporteur mais
mes chers collègues notre groupe partage
avec regret le constat alarmant qui a
été tiré des états généraux de la
justice les mots ont été durs mais ils
sont réels le système judiciaire
français est dans un état de délabrement
il est au bord de la rupture le texte de
la programmation qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui propose une hausse de 9,6 à
10,7 milliards d'euros pour l'objet de
la justice sur la période 2023 2027
cette augmentation des crédits est à
saluer nous ont convenons tous mais ce
budget supplémentaire conséquent ne
saurait que le débat sur la justice de
ce pays bien évidemment on peut observer
malgré tout que la trajectoire du budget
justice reste limitée si on la compare
avec celle de l'Intérieur au-delà du
satisfait site budgétaire globale
exprimée par le gouvernement plusieurs
points de ces deux textes interpellent
les membres de notre groupe d'une part
ces projets de loi comportent des
dispositions à risque vis-à-vis des
libertés publiques c'est un débat
récurrent et nous interroge dans leur
application sur le long terme
d'autre part on ne s'attaque pas
suffisamment selon nous au manque
d'effectif dans certains territoires en
particulier pour les juridictions en
outre-mer et en Corse il faut des
effectifs durables et non des mesures
temporaires même si elles sont si elles
sont là si elles sont éclairantes et
qu'elles permettent de donner une
réponse nous demandons des engagements
clairs pour ces territoires face au
manque d'effectif de manière pérenne
vous connaissez le contexte Corse ou le
crime organisé la dérivation il faut
appeler un chat un chat doivent être
combattus sans relâche en mettant en
oeuvre les moyens qu'il faut quitte à
oser modifier l'arsenal législatives si
cela est nécessaire est proportionné
nous portons un certain nombre
d'amendements importants sur ce sujet
grave et le débat continuera sur ce
point néanmoins nous saluons la volonté
du garde des sceaux de dédier des
mesures à ces territoires exposés à des
difficultés d'attractivité les honorales
l'outre-mer la Corse qui souffrent de ce
manque de personnel la création du
dispositif contractuelle le priorité
d'affectation aux contrepartie pour les
magistrats qui aurait accepté une
nomination dans son territoire peu
attractif va dans le bon sens nous
espérons que cela participe une logique
incitative que notre groupe soutient
nous avons corrigé en commission le
recul voter au Sénat sur l'article 5 du
projet de l'organique en rétablissant le
texte initial les sénateurs étaient
revenus sur les renforts temporaires de
magistrats issus de l'Hexagone en Corse
notamment mais nous le répétons ce sont
plus des effectifs permanents dont nous
avons besoin que des affectations
ponctuelles cependant l'état s'est
renfort temporaire son bois prendre nous
les saluons vous annoncer 1500
registrats supplémentaires autant de
greffiers supplémentaires qui sont à
lancer c'est très bien mais la
problématique des difficultés de
recrutement ne risque-t-elle pas
d'empêcher le ministère d'atteindre ses
objectifs c'est une question que nous
vous posons c'est un point crucial à
l'autre sens à chaque budget nous en
avons eu de 16 souligner également le
manque d'attractivité des métiers de la
pénitentiaire nous soutenons votre
proposition de création d'un statut de
surveillant adjoint mais cette mesure
seule selon nous ne suffira pas c'est un
travail global qu'il faut mener de fond
en comble on y rajoutant le problème de
surpopulation carcérale notre collègue
Carolina Abadie a formulé des solutions
intéressantes j'espère nous espérons
qu'elle se concrétiseront durant cet
examen en séance une autre critique que
souhaite expérimenter une autre groupe
c'est la l'aspect dense du texte
l'article 3 qui comporte plus d'une
dizaine de mesures lourdes de
conséquences n'ont parfois pas de lien
entre elles dans le même sens si nous
soutenons la volonté de réécrire le code
de procédure pénal pour le rendre plus
lisible le choix les ordonnances est
toujours au gretables de manière
générale ce que nous déplorons c'est que
chaque texte sur la justice déploie son
lot de mesure qui porte une atteinte
grave aux libertés publiques comme je
l'ai dit précédemment nous sommes
opposés l'article 3 ce n'est pas une
nouveauté comment ne pas être alerté sur
l'activation à distance des téléphones
portables et ordinateurs à l'issue à
l'insu du propriétaire dans le but de
les géolocaliser en temps réel voire
même de les mettre sur écoute et de les
filmer
jusqu'où irons-nous bien qu'il s'agit
simplement pour vous de légaliser des
pratiques déjà mises en oeuvre est-ce
qu'il y aura une limite aux grands
délinquants ou étendrons-nous ces
possibilités de contrôle au petit délit
comment allons-nous encadrer les abus
des services d'enquêtes car il y en a eu
il y en aura c'est certain je crois que
cette mesure nous fait franchir un
nouveau cap dangereux mais nous en
débattrons le Conseil d'État lui-même
souligne l'attente importante au droit à
la vie privée tout comme l'extension du
recours aux perquisition de nuit ou
encore la problématique de recours à la
télémédecine en garde à vue à ce stade
pour l'instant je donnerai pas encore de
position globale du groupe sur le vote
final le sujet des deux textes nous
attendons évidemment la discussion en
séance et le sort réservé à nos
amendements je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Aquaviva
la parole est à Madame sans rate Sarah
tanzy lit pour le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
il y a six jours un garçon de 17 ans
Naël perdait la vie lors d'un contrôle
de police la France se réveillait sonnée
par un drame qui n'aurait jamais dû se
produire elle compatissait avec les
proches de la victime et les images de
Nanterre nous bouleversaient tous mais
rien ne justifie les images qui leur
succédèrent rien ne justifie les
pillages les incendies le recours à la
violence contre nos forces de police de
gendarmerie et de secours je leur
adresse au nom du groupe Renaissance
tout mon soutien tous mes remerciements
pour l'engagement et le calme dont ils
ont fait preuve durant ces nuits
d'émeutes dans notre pays enfin jamais
je dis bien jamais amer ne doit pouvoir
craindre pour sa vie et celle de sa
famille à son domicile je soutiens là
encore au nom du groupe Renaissance
Vincent Jean Brun mère de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses et tous nos élus
municipaux en première ligne pour faire
face au chaos
en ce jour profondément dramatique dont
notre pays nous pourrions parler social
logement parentalité réseaux sociaux
relations police population nous
pourrions parler politique de la ville
ou école de la République mais nous
sommes réunis pour parler justice une
institution déterminante pour apporter
les premières réponses à ces événements
alors notre responsabilité en tant que
décideur public ce n'est pas d'appeler à
l'insurrection comme certains l'ont fait
ce n'est pas de nous substituer à la
justice qui a agi vite et fort avec la
mise en examen et le placement des
tensions provisoires du policier auteur
du tir contre Naël d'une part et 570 des
ferments prononcés en trois jours contre
des auteurs de violence d'autre part
notre responsabilité c'est de permettre
à la justice de faire correctement son
travail et cette majorité sera au
rendez-vous en soutenant un projet de
loi dont l'ambition est simple mais
essentielle donner enfin à la justice
les moyens dont elle a si cruellement
manqué pendant des années pour
fonctionner
sur le plan financier d'abord avec 7,5
milliards d'euros supplémentaires d'ici
2027 qui viendront s'ajouter aux
augmentations budgétaires successives
depuis 2017 et qui permettront au budget
justice d'augmenter de 60% en 10 ans ces
moyens vont nous permettre de mieux
rémunérer les agents de l'institution
judiciaire d'embaucher 10 000 agents
supplémentaires dont 1500 magistrats et
1500 greffiers de créer 15000 places de
prison avec les personnels correspondant
d'agrandir et de moderniser nos palais
de justice et de permettre à
l'institution judiciaire de ce numériser
entièrement gagnant ainsi en efficacité
et en rapidité donner à la justice les
moyens de fonctionner ces pérenniser la
construction d'une équipe autour du
magistrat avec le recrutement des
attachés de justice ces fameux sucres
lents dont nous avions tant besoin
donnez à la justice les moyens de
fonctionner ces modifier la loi
organique afin de permettre au corps
judiciaires de s'ouvrir vers l'extérieur
et de diversifier les profils
l'intégrant donner à la justice les
moyens de fonctionner c'est autoriser
nos forces d'investigation à rec de
nouvelles techniques d'enquête plus
modernes donner à la justice les moyens
de fonctionner c'est interroger son
organisation actuelle en remodelant le
champ d'intervention du juge des
libertés des tensions en transférant les
saisies rémunérations commissaire de
justice en développant la médiation en
matière civile en expérimentant le
Tribunal des affaires économiques et la
contribution pour la justice économique
donner à la justice les moyens de
fonctionner c'est enfin mieux indemniser
les victimes on élargissant le champ des
infractions recevables à la commission
d'indemnisation des victimes
d'infraction ce projet de loi est une
nécessité impérieuse il vient participer
à corriger 30 années d'abandon de notre
institution judiciaire que nous ne
pouvons plus décemment laisser perdurer
car nous avons tous pu le constater
durant les jours qui se sont écoulés où
il n'y a point de justice il n'y a point
de République la justice et la garantie
de notre paix sociale de notre capacité
à faire société ensemble la situation de
chaos qui a frappé notre pays les
profondes fractures qu'elles révèle
exige de nous tous mesures
responsabilité et j'ose le dire unité je
déplore qu'un groupe politique est déjà
attesté de son irresponsabilité en
déposant une motion de rejet mais je ne
perds pas espoir mes chers collègues que
dans ce contexte dramatique nous
entendions nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens et nous arrivions à montrer
un exemple de responsabilité et d'unités
en vue de renforcer une institution
judiciaire qui en a tant besoin et en
adoptant largement ce projet de loi
essentiel je vous remercie
merci Madame Tanzilli la parole est à
Monsieur Philippe Shrek pour le groupe
rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs chers
collègues
est-ce que la loi de programmation
comporte des opérations et des
orientations souhaitables oui
est-ce que cette loi répond aux
préoccupations de nos concitoyens
assurément non va-t-elle permettre de
lutter contre l'insécurité
l'ensauvagement et le déferlement de
haine que nous subissons non incendié
incendiaire et meetiers pilleurs
casseurs voleur
ultra violent encouragé par des pseudos
révolutionnaires inconscients pourront à
l'issue du vote de ces lois dormir
tranquille surtout la journée
cette loi poursuit les politiques ont
abouti à une justice longue
incomprise qui ne contribue plus à
garantir la paix sociale et qui n'est
pas dissuasive monsieur le ministre
votre exercice de programmation rime
avec déclaration d'intention
d'autosatisfaction d'autochondratulation
sur des choses qui n'ont pas encore été
réalisées et que pour diverses raisons
vous ne réaliserez sûrement pas bien
entendu la précédente période de
programmation a connu une hausse des
budgets et il y aura une progression
bienvenue en début de période qui sera
demeurant neutralisée par l'inflation
mais nul n'ignore à quel point nous
partons de loin tant il est vrai que les
quinquennats de Messieurs Sarkozy et
Hollande au sein duquel monsieur Macron
a pris une part pour le moins active
furent pour la justice 10 ans de
calvaire budgétaire et humain
de plus les trois dernières années de la
période de programmation seront marqués
par la stagnation le budget de la
justice n'augmentera plus à l'inverse
des dépenses et des besoins
nous serons en soutien des dispositifs
qui permettent de traquer les criminels
et la délinquance s'organiser notamment
en termes de perquisition de nuit et de
techniques modernes d'enquête il est
inconcevable que les délinquants et le
crime organisé disposent des
technologies du 21e siècle et que les
enquêteurs soient souvent au périls de
leur sécurité maintenu dans celles du
20e
le statut des magistrats est censé être
amélioré
gageons que ces améliorations
profiteront au vrai serviteurs de l'État
qui sont très majoritaires et non pas
des juges politisés réunis dans un
syndicat qui affiche sa haine de la
police rien pour les greffiers ou des
mesures en trompe l'oeil rien pour ceux
qui sont indispensables à l'oeuvre de la
justice et qui a l'occasion du début de
nos travaux sont en grève dans les
tribunaux et cours de France
j’évoquais les crânes des Français pas
grand chose pas un dispositif sur la
délinquance des étrangers pas une idée
visant à améliorer le traitement des
contentieux administratifs à aborder le
problème central des occultés F du
traitement pénal des déliers des crimes
commis par nos collègues par les
étrangers souvent en situation
irrégulière sur nos sols pour ce
gouvernement ce phénomène ne semble pas
exister dont acte nous continuons bien
entendu à soutenir le plan de 15000
places de prison même s'il devient il
faut le constater un serpent de mer
malheureusement il nous le regrettons ce
plan ne sera pas finalisé dans les
délais promis il apparaîtra rapidement
sous-dimensionné au regard des mots de
notre société et aux besoins d'une
politique pénale qui se doit d'endiguer
la progression continue des violences
faites aux personnes tout en
garantissant des conditions de détention
dignes
nous posons une question
pourquoi créer des milliers de place de
prison pour continuer à promouvoir une
politique de zéro emprisonnement
notamment pour les courtes peines cette
politique est de plus en plus visible
elle accorde au délinquant une impunité
de fêtes insupportable aux françaises et
aux Français elle érige un mur
d'incompréhension entre la justice et la
police elle est le terreau de la
réitération des crimes et des délits
cette démission malheureusement est
aussi la cause de ce qui se passe dans
nos quartiers lorsque nous évoquons
l'administration pénitentiaire il faut
évoquer les prêts de 40000 femmes et
hommes qui la servent longtemps négligé
victime de conditions de travail de plus
en plus dégradé l'État a créé les
conditions durables de la désaffection
de leur métier
le groupe rassemblement national prend
acte de quelques améliorations
approuvent l'instauration de la réserve
pénitentiaire mais de me reposer à la
création d'un statut d'agent contractuel
qui est une précarisation voire une
paupérisation des métiers de
l'Administration Pénitentiaire bien
entendu les débats il accueille réservé
à nos propositions conditionneront notre
vote mais d'ores et déjà il faut le dire
il s'agit d'une loi de faible envergure
d'une loi dépourvue de colonne
vertébrale d'un dispositif sans cape
nous savons en revanche que la prochaine
loi de programmation de la justice en
2027 ouvrira vraisemblablement des
perspectives fortes pour aider le pays
et incarnera les signaux du réveil et
pour cause c'est nous qui la porterons
[Applaudissements]
la parole
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs
pas de justice pas de paix notre
responsabilité de représentante et de
représentants de la nation et lui par le
peuple revêt toute son importance en ce
jour de début d'examen de ce texte et
dans le contexte actuel au regard de
l'enjeu au regard de l'état de défiance
des citoyennes et des citoyens à l'égard
de la justice au regard de la saturation
des tribunaux au regard de la
surpopulation carcérale le gouvernement
envoie un mauvais signal dès le départ
par cette procédure accélérée dispositif
qui devrait être exception pardon mais
qui devient hélas la règle bien sûr il y
aura eu au préalable les états généraux
de la justice mais ces propositions sont
quasi absentes dans ce texte et puis il
y aurait eu une grande concertation avec
les syndicats qui n'aura été selon les
intéressés eux-mêmes comme de comme dans
le texte organique les quelques avancées
sur les conditions de travail des
magistrats ne sauraient effacer le
projet de flexibilité dans
l'organisation de la magistrature le
recours à la précarisation ou le report
de l'âge d'exercice des magistrats
honoraires ou à titre temporaire à 75
ans ces dispositions ne constituent pas
une réponse pérenne aux besoins et vont
à l'encontre même des revendications des
syndicats que vous refusez d'entendre
monsieur le ministre et même d'écouter
entendez-vous l'Association européenne
des magistrats dont la motion adoptée à
l'unanimité préconise au gouvernement
français de ne pas introduire certaines
dispositions disciplinaires de l'article
8 comme la communication des décisions
d'irrecevabilité des plaintes des
justiciables au ministre lequel pourra
alors ordonner tout en quête de
magistrats
contre les magistrats concernés puis
saisir lui-même le Conseil supérieur de
la magistrature les syndicats de
magistrats alertent aussi sur ces
risques de gestion infradisciplinaires
et de conflits
impliquent sommes-nous en gris
sommes-nous en Pologne la situation ne
serait pas aussi dramatique si notre
actuelle garde des sceaux n'était pas
déjà mis un examen pour prise illégal
d'intérêt devant la Cour de Justice de
la République soupçonnés d'avoir
déstabilisé des magistrats
votre loi de programmation montre aussi
que vous n'écoutez personne monsieur le
ministre ni les personnels
pénitentiaires ni les greffières et les
greffiers mobilisés aujourd'hui en masse
pour une augmentation conséquente de
leur grille indiciaire vous allez même
jusqu'à provoquer en ouvrant la réserve
des surveillants à 67 ans juste après la
loi sur les retraites passer en force à
coup de 49,3 que tout le peuple garde
encore en mémoire monsieur le ministre
30 ans de politique carcérales et pénale
inefficace vous contemple les états
généraux de la justice les avocats les
magistrats le personnel pénitentiaire la
contrôleuse des lieux de privation de
liberté le Conseil de l'Europe tous
préconisent d'instituées un mécanisme de
régulation carcérale mais vous restez
sourd à la règle de base plus on
construit plus en enferme vous préférez
annoncer la construction de 15000 places
supplémentaires en cédant aux sirènes de
la droite et de l'extrême droite dans le
sillage de votre collègue de l'Intérieur
vous présentez des mesures liberticides
activation la distance d'appareils
connectés sans ou le consentement de la
personne ainsi écoutée ainsi surveiller
au plus près de sa vie intime extension
du régime des perquisitions de nuit au
crime de droit commun tout cela le
rapport sauvé que vous dites respecter
n'en parle pas alors que tous vos
personnels exigent plus de moyens que le
peuple demande un service public de
justice plus proche plus efficace vos
réponses ne montrent aucune audace
reproduisant des schémas
inefficaces et dépassés ces textes ne
vont pas dans le bon sens nous les
amenderons afin de leur donner la bonne
direction en espérant être écouté et ne
pas recevoir systématiquement des avis
défavorables sinon on ne retiendra de ce
budget historique qu'il ne représente
que la moitié de celui de la police je
vous remercie
merci Madame thorignat
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Gosselin pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vont
permettre en tant que Normand de rendre
un hommage si vous le voulez bien un
grand monsieur qui vient de nous quitter
un grand normand un grand français le
dernier des commandos qui fait Léon
Gauthier
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie pour lui pour ces
hommes qu'il représente et j'en viens
sans doute en transition maladroite au
sujet du jour la réforme de la justice
dans un contexte si différent de celui
que nous avons connu il y a encore une
semaine j'évoque évidemment les
bâtiments publics saccagés les commerces
volés vandalisés et l'ensemble des faits
qui se déroulent après la mort de Naël
dans les silences coupables des uns les
propos ambigus des autres nous voulons
appeler nous les républicains à la
fermeté et à l'exemplarité si les causes
sont multiples des réponses à apporter
dans les cours moyen terme
l'immédiateté n'est pas à la faiblesse
et que dire aussi de ses élus attaqués
le mandat des Lucas de mère en
particulier est-il devenu à ce point
dangereux nous avions le décès du maire
de Sinne nous avions la démission du
maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins
maintenant c'est Vincent Jean Brun que
je salue que nous sout comme l'ensemble
je l'espère de la représentation
nationale que nous accompagnons nous
pensons à son épouse à ses enfants oui
quand la République n'est pas capable de
protéger ses élus elle se met elle-même
en danger c'est la République elle-même
que l'on Bafou les mères sont les
sentinelles de nos petites républiques
qui font de la grande il faut comme pour
toutes ces questions comme pour tous les
citoyens pour toutes ces questions qui
touchent à la sécurité une protection
exemplaire il faut des mesures fortes à
la hauteur des enjeux et victimes une
politique pénale assurée et assumée une
politique pénale rapide ferme et
systématique alors nous en arrivons
évidemment au coeur de notre sujet un
projet de loi organique et un projet de
loi ordinaire est-ce la fin de la
clochardille la clochardisation pardon
de la justice nous le verrons il y a des
moyens financiers c'est vrai nous
verrons s'ils sont à la hauteur nous
serons vigilant en tout cas pour
l'utilisation des crédits et surtout
leur bonne utilisation leur bonne
exécution des moyens humains magistrats
greffiers surveillants 10000 c'est un
enjeu évidemment important de
recrutement de formation d'attractivité
et ce n'est pas si facile que cela à
mettre en œuvre il y aura aussi des
réductions délais de la justice en tout
cas c'est le pari qui est fait une
refonte de la procédure pénale une
amélioration des conditions de travail
des juges normalement et en principe
tout cela s'est très bien mais
n'oublions pas aussi que s'il y a la
métropole les outre-mer et je pense à
Mayotte aussi en particulier ne sont pas
sur la touche et ne doivent pas l'être
mais des questions demeurent et sont
évidemment peu satisfaisantes
aujourd'hui beaucoup de sanctions ne
sont pas appliquées on a une forme
depuis 10 ans de désarmement pénal
disant parce que j'évoque évidemment le
ministère de Christiane Taubira qui
avait donné un très mauvais signal
pourquoi par ailleurs ne pas rétablir
les peines plancher c'est un signal que
vous pourriez envoyer monsieur le
ministre de votre vigueur de votre
rigueur et de la justice que nous
voulons exemplaire et puis quelques mots
sur les places de prison c'est
évidemment un sujet important pour nous
pas simplement parce que nous serions
ultra sécuritaire mais parce qu'il y a
une surpopulation carcérale nous
manquons de place de prison et puis il y
a un objectif c'est l'encellulement
individuel en 2027 et le compte avec le
plan 15000 n'y est pas en réalité comme
l'a dit notre collègue Patrick Hetzel il
y a une forme de procrastination depuis
de longues années le compte n'y est pas
nous n'avons pas les 15000 les 15000
places est un plan qui avait été annoncé
en 2018 il visait à créer 7000 places en
2022 et 8000 à l'horizon 2027 vous savez
bien qu'au 31 12 2022 il y a eu
précisément
2441 places nouvelle seulement de créer
et de constater on est très très loin du
compte un retard énorme les 13415 places
qui restent à ouvrir le serait pour
l'essentiel près de la moitié à la fin
de 2025 donc nous vous proposons d'aller
au-delà d'avoir une trajectoire
budgétaire revue et de faire confiance à
ces mères qui sont prêts à accueillir
chez eux des prisons il n'y a pas que
ceux qui rejettent il y en a qui sont
prêts à le faire et puis évidemment il y
aura d'autres points à évoquer comme
l'exécution des peines nous sommes très
loin du compte nous devons être
exemplaires pour les victimes nous
devons être exemplaires pour cette
justice qui est rendue au nom du peuple
français alors nous verrons en
conclusion quels seront les avancées
dans les heures qui viennent et c'est ce
qui déterminera notre vote je vous
remercie merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur emmanuellement
donc pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur les rapporteurs
chers collègues
la justice est garante de la démocratie
les deux projets de loi que nous
examinons
prennent encore plus de sens aujourd'hui
au regard de la violence aveugle qui
secoue notre pays
depuis 2017 avec 6 réformes législatives
successives votre prédécesseur et
vous-même monsieur le ministre vous êtes
ainsi attelé à redonner à notre justice
les moyens pour remplir son rôle
fondamental qui est d'assurer le respect
des règles de vie en société
indéniablement ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui avec une particulière acuité
c'est l'affirmation de l'État de droit
et du respect par tous
de la loi et du droit
le groupe démocrate salue votre
engagement et la constance de la méthode
que vous avez choisie c'est le garde des
sceaux qui repose sur la consultation et
l'écoute de ceux qui font ou ont à faire
à la justice de notre pays les états
généraux de la justice en sont une
illustration réussie
et nous soulignons bien sûr en premier
lieu les efforts budgétaires en
constante augmentation depuis 6 ans et
nous ne pouvons que soutenir l'effort
inédit aujourd'hui proposé
oui les moyens augmentent
considérablement mais il ne prendront
tout leur sens que s'ils sont déployés
au service d'une justice plus rapide et
réaliste et d'une politique rénovée des
services judiciaires et des juridictions
et c'est bien l'objectif de vos deux
textes après l'ouverture de plusieurs
chantiers que je voudrais rappeler
tout d'abord répondre avec fermeté
lorsque c'est nécessaire aux agressions
qui minent notre société par un
traitement attentif et dédié je pense en
particulier ou violence intra-familiale
favoriser le recours systématique aux
travaux d'intérêt général trop peu
utilisé comme peine de substitution
à la prison en particulier auprès des
jeunes
déchargez le contentieux ordinaire par
la voie judiciaire
en imposant une véritable révolution de
l'amiable
expérimenter des formes nouvelles de
contentieux notamment en matière
commerciale
décentralisée la gestion matérielle des
juridictions tout en modernisant par le
recours au numérique
la refonte envisagée du code de
procédure pénale vise à rendre le droit
compréhensible à tous cela a été dit
tout en assurant une réponse adaptée à
l'évolution des comportements délictueux
au-delà du droit constant il faudra
réfléchir rapidement à la manière de
rétablir le rapport de certains jeunes à
la loi
en tirant les leçons des événements
actuels
comme vous l'avez reconnu la réforme ne
serait-être accomplie sans que le
Parlement y soit étroitement associé ces
enjeux démocratiques et sociétaux sont
sans trop notre groupe a pris une
initiative afin d'inscrire dans la loi
la procédure correspondante la tension
notre groupe c'est également porté sur
le délicat équilibre
entre le maintien de l'ordre public et
le respect des libertés fondamentales
que posent des innovations
certes indispensables comme
l'exploitation des données
issues de la géolocalisation ou
l'extension des perquisations des
perquisitions pardon de nuit nous sommes
également conscients qu'une des clés de
réussite de cette politique est
l'adhésion des personnels
magistrats greffier personnel
pénitentiaire notamment et les avocats
acteurs pivot de la justice
les revalorisations de traitement sont
une des mesures contribuant certainement
à cet objectif
plus largement notre groupe relève avec
satisfaction les innovations que
constitue la consécration de l'équipe
qui entoure les magistrats la
redéfinition et la stabilisation des
missions des personnels contractuelles
tout en approuvant le principe du un
concours professionnel nouveau qui
permettra d'augmenter le nombre de
magistrats pour des vides nécessité
notre groupe peut souhaite veiller à la
qualité des procédures de recrutement et
mieux réguler l'accès à la magistrature
permis par ce concours professionnel par
ailleurs le groupe démocrate comprend
les inquiétudes de certaines catégories
de personnels face au développement
accrue des recrutements par voie
contractuelle d'attacher de justice et
de surveillance prison adjoint il
souhaite qu'une attention particulière
soit portée à la qualité des
recrutements ainsi opérés à nouveau
c'est donc une question
délicate peut-être plus délicate qu'il
faut pratiquer un équilibre entre
contingence je termine budgétaire et
réactivité et la nécessité de préserver
la qualité attendue par les justiciables
de la justice le groupe démocrate
s'engage dans ce débat monsieur garde
des sceaux à vos côtés de manière
résolue et exigeante au service d'une
idée de justice garante des droits
fondamentaux je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame Cécile
et apparenté
bonjour
on monte là je crois voilà merci bien
alors madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs monsieur le
rapporteur général Jean Tellier
messieurs les rapporteurs Erwan Balanant
Philippe Pradal Didier Paris chers
collègues
en préambule je dirais que ce débat
s'ouvre dans un contexte douloureux
nos pensées vont bien sûr à ce jeu de
Naël de 17 ans mais aussi
aux forces de police et de gendarmerie
et Homer politique de proximité
qui nous rappelle aujourd'hui combien la
proximité est essentielle
et que c'est peut-être la leçon des
événements actuels et ceci est valable
pour la justice dont l'indépendance ne
doit pas signifier l'indifférence la
différence au territoire
alors en préambule de ce texte je ferai
trois observations la première c'est que
73% des Français affirment que la
justice fonctionne mal cette défiance
est alarmante la justice doit retrouver
la confiance démocratique elle le doit
puisque la fragilité d'un système
judiciaire peut être le cheval de Troie
d'un éventuel exécutif et prix
d'autoritarisme les régimes polonaise et
hongrois le démontre en sévissant contre
les minorités et en bafouant les
principes les plus consubstantiels de
l'État de droit notre rôle de
législateur est d'engager ici la justice
dans la voie d'une réforme systémique de
conserver l'équilibre avec une justice
indépendante dotée des moyens qu'elle
requiert pour assurer sa mission
nous devons aussi questionner
l'intelligence artificielle la justice
digitale l'informatisation du droit qui
modifie l'élaboration de la loi il
s'agit pour nous de mettre les moyens
sur ce sujet pour dessiner le chemin de
la justice dans ce nouvel univers quel
est l'engagement du Gouvernement sur ce
point monsieur le ministre nous
examinons ici en fin de texte un projet
de loi organique qui ouvre les voies
d'accès à la magistrature nous voulons
vous convaincre d'associer plus avant
les universitaires et adopter des
amendements de claques
du juge et de déontologie à nos yeux et
les essentiels sous réserve de ses
avancées nous trouverons ce texte plutôt
bon
un projet de loi ordinaire qui porte
d'abord une majoration de crédits à
saluer et une ordonnance qui porte
codification du code de procédure pénale
et enfin un rapport annexé qui concentre
nos insatisfactions nos espérances
canalisent nos frustrations sans effet
normatif il nous libère des articles 40
et 45 des capitaux de nos innovations
alors mon premier point ça sera une
réforme systémique appelée par Jean-Marc
Sauvé que je soutiens et qui implique la
réforme un budget vous y répondez par
une augmentation substantielle des
moyens budgétaires une révolution
numérique qui impose une réorganisation
des services judiciaires et de la
déconcentration une poursuite de la
collégialité en construisant une équipe
autour du magistrat associant les
existence c'est-à-dire les greffiers et
en faisant appel aux forces vives du
droit une considération de l'ensemble
des acteurs auxiliaires justice
greffiers acteurs du SPIP je pense aussi
aux éducateurs spécialisés de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse en
sous-effectif en manque de moyens et en
perte d'attractivité je pense aussi que
cette réforme systémique appelle le
placement du juge au cœur du litige et
nous sommes nous soutenons tous là tout
ce que je viens d'énumérer et qui se
retrouve dans le texte en revanche
la réforme des saisies rémunération et
le transfert des compétences des
activités agricoles et des associations
au tribunaux des activités économiques
ne nous paraissent pas répondre à cet
objectif de placer le juge au cœur du
litige pour ce dernier pour le Tae c'est
une occasion manquée nous semble-t-il de
fédérer les professionnels du droit et
les sachants du monde de l'entreprise et
pour la première s'agissant des saisies
rémunérations qui concernent les
populations vulnérables c'est finalement
complexifier voire ne plus permettre en
réalité le recours au juge
en deuxième fois je dirais que c'est une
réforme systémique qui ne doit pas
oublier ses fondamentaux le premier
c'est une prison qui punit bien sûr et
qui réinsère 15000 places de prison ne
pourront pas être délivrés en 2027
malgré votre volonté les prisons
resteront surpeuplées et perdurera un
système aussi coûteux
inefficace celui d'une usine à récidive
dans laquelle les conditions sociales et
psychologiques des 73800 détenus se
dégradent sous écrou le constat est sans
appel le taux de récidive atteint près
de 40%, le débat donc doit prospérer
sans propos populistes et avec courage
le deuxième fondament enjeu fondamental
c'est une indépendance qui protège le
JLD est un acteur essentiel dans la
présence doit être renforcée le
troisième point c'est une indépendance
qui n'est pas l'indifférence parce que
la justice est au service des citoyens
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir dans un
contexte de colère sachons retrouver les
voies de la construction dans un débat
apaisé et respectueux
je vous remercie madame huternaillère
la parole est à Monsieur Jérémy urdanov
pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le garde des sceaux messieurs
les rapporteurs chers collègues la
justice entendez comme ce mot résonne
elle ne peut pas tout bien sûr elle ne
se substitue pas à la politique mais
sans elle point de concorde point de
paix civil son organisation est
indissociable de l'État de droit il faut
lui donner les moyens adéquats et la
protéger contre toute interférence
l'autorité judiciaire c'est un pouvoir
c'est une institution ce sont des règles
ce sont des procédures ce sont aussi des
femmes et des hommes après la tribune
des 3000 après les états généraux de la
justice les deux textes que nous allons
discuter étaient attendus certaines
dispositions vont dans le bon sens mais
disons-le aussi elle ne répondent pas à
l'ensemble des problèmes
volumineux et touchant des points
essentiels il est fort dommageable que
le gouvernement est une fois de plus
recours à la procédure accélérée sur ce
texte cela n'est pas respectueux de la
délibération parlementaire et se fait au
détriment de la qualité du droit avant
d'aborder le texte je veux dire un mot
de ces silences
il est regrettable que le débat
institutionnel sur l'autorité judiciaire
n'est pas eu lieu alors où la France
devrait faire un pas de plus vers la
parfaite indépendance de sa justice nous
assistons plutôt un mouvement inverse
je pense en particulier à la
transmission au ministre des plaintes
zérocevables de plus la main mise du
parquet sur les enquêtes et les
poursuites à déséquilibrer la procédure
pénale et pose d'autant plus la question
de son statut et de son indépendance
c'était une demande des états généraux
de la justice et du CSM silence radio
aussi sur l'indépendance de la justice
vis-à-vis de l'administration ce qui
concerne les atteintes à l'environnement
le contentieux pénal de l'environnement
est à sec
il y a évidemment le manque de moyens
dédié à la recherche et la poursuite de
la délinquance environnementale mais il
y a surtout le fait que les parquets ne
sont pas saisis par les services
verbalisateurs placés sous l'autorité
des préfectures lesquelles son
notoirement sensibles aux intérêts
économiques locaux les affaires pour
lesquelles les préfets ont délivré des
autorisations illégales où on laissait
sciemment des industries polluer ne
manquent pas le phénomène est ancien et
documenté cette rétention de
l'information conduit à déplacer le
principe d'opportunités des poursuites
au sein des administrations en lui et
place de l'autorité judiciaire c'est une
atteinte au principe de séparation des
pouvoirs nous avons déposé plusieurs
amendements pour faire évoluer ces
pratiques nous félicitons que le
gouvernement et accepté de soutenir l'un
d'entre eux en commission et nous
espérons les voir prospérer les autres
en séance
un mot sur l'extension nécessaire du
référé pénal environnemental j'avais un
amendement en commission repoussé parce
que m'a-t-on dit insuffisamment précis
il a été retravaillé pourtant déclaré
irrecevable pour la séance je le
regrette vivement
autre lacunes du texte la question de la
surpopulation carcérale je ne reviens
pas sur les conditions indignes de
détention tous les leviers n'ont pas été
activés l'aménagement de PN nécessite du
temps et des moyens dont nous dispose
pas le juge correctionnel je propose de
redonner toute sa place au juge de
l'application des peines un mécanique de
régulation est également nécessaire des
propositions mesurées ont été faites par
nos collègues Abadie et faussillon que
je salue je veux dénoncer sur ce point
le manque de courage politique du
gouvernement
sur les grandes lignes du projet les
forts budgétaires et les recrutements
annoncés je les saluent très clairement
les sommes débloquées permettront de
soulager une institution en crise
profonde mais soulager seulement la
guérison attendra par ailleurs une
aucune précision sur la ventilation des
crédits le législateur ne peut se
satisfaire d'un chiffre brut qui
pourrait cacher une mauvaise répartition
un mot sur les dérives il y a dans ce
texte des mesures qui privent les
parties d'un accès à une justice
équitable et impartial je pense par
exemple au saisines sur rémunération à
la contribution pour la justice
économique mais aussi au transfert à un
juge non spécialisé d'une partie des
compétences du juge des libertés et de
la détention plutôt que de réduire le
champ d'intervention du JLD il
conviendrait de renforcer ses moyens
d'action en le dotant d'une équipe pour
créer les conditions d'une véritable
indépendance vis-à-vis des acteurs de
l'enquête
l'extension des pouvoirs d'enquêtes nous
semblent également très problématique on
ne peut pas toujours sacrifier les
libertés publiques à des questions
pratiques à ce titre l'activation à
distance des téléphones portables à des
fins géolocalisation et d'écoute pose
question je m'inquiète des dérives
possibles et des volumes permis par ces
nouvelles techniques quant à l'extension
des perquisitions nocturnes aux crimes
de droit commun rien ne justifie la
généralisation de ce procédé en dehors
évidemment des cas complexes les
écologistes déterminant leur vote en
fonction des avancées adoptées ou non en
séance je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur Yordanov et je
vais suspendre la séance pour une durée
de 10 minutes
la séance est ouverte bonjour à tous
Tout d'abord remerciements à la
présidente muchu qui a eu l'élégance
l'efficacité de me remplacer alors que
j'étais retenu alors que c'était mon
tour de président mille merci chers
collègues d'avoir fait tourner la maison
avec la rigueur et l'efficacité que nous
vous connaissons nous reprenons le cours
de la discussion générale et pour le
groupe GDR c'est Madame Émeline carbidy
qui a la parole pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
quand un jeune de 17 ans meurt d'une
balle tirée par un policier c'est tout
un pays qui crie justice
quand des représentants des forces de
l'ordre sont blessés ou pire perdre la
vie dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions
nous convoquons la justice
quand un commerçant voit disparaître son
outil de travail dans les flammes et le
pillage nous réclamons la justice
quand ta mère et sa famille sont
attaqués en pleine nuit à leur domicile
le pays entier se lève pour exiger que
justice soit faite
la justice ne rend pas les vies perdues
mais la justice amène la paix la paix
sociale
sur les murs des cités qui s'embrassent
depuis plusieurs jours on peut
d'ailleurs lire pas de justice pas de
paix
voyez donc l'importance que chacun
accorde à la justice dans notre pays les
exigences et l'espoir que nous mettons
en elle
dans un monde de plus en plus injuste où
les inégalités ne cessent de se creuser
la justice est de plus en plus
sollicitée
et alors que nous sommes si exigeants à
son égard certains oublient parfois
qu'elle est rendue au nom du peuple
français par des femmes et des hommes
dont l'engagement n'a d'égal que
l'importance de leur mission
pour les magistrats les greffiers les
assistantes justice les avocats les
commissaires de justice et tous les
autres auxiliaires la justice n'est pas
qu'une valeur un idéal pour eux la
justice et palpable elle se compte en
milliers d'heures de travail en
centaines de dossiers à traiter elle a
le visage des femmes et des hommes des
enfants que l'on juge eux attendent plus
que des mots ou des regrets même si
après des décennies de délaissement
de la justice dans notre pays des
regrets nous en avons forcément autant
vous dire Monsieur le Ministre que votre
projet de loi pour la justice était fort
attendu nous attendions des moyens
humains et matériels et vous avez
annoncé il est vrai le recrutement de
1500 magistrats et greffiers sur cinq
ans quand bien même une telle mesure
aurait été annoncée sous la mandature
précédente il en manquerait encore mais
nous sommes en 2023 et les moyens ne
sont pas à la hauteur de l'urgence
les comparaisons européennes nous
rappellent combien nous pouvons et
devons faire mieux la France dépend 72
euros par an et par habitant pour son
système judiciaire c'est 88 euros en
Espagne ou 141 euros en Allemagne pour
100000 habitants en France nous avons
trois procureurs ont juge 34 greffiers
en Europe c'est 11 procureurs 18 juges
61 greffiers et les délais de traitement
des dossiers ne sont pas meilleurs en
France en première instance il faut 637
jours pour traiter un dossier ces 237
pour le reste de l'Europe en appel 607
jours en France
177 chez nos voisins européens
je suis bien navrée de vous avoir noyé
sous les chiffres mais voyez-vous nos
magistrats et greffiers eux sont noyés
sous les dossiers qui ne parviennent
plus à traiter le rapport sauvé illustre
la détresse des professionnels de la
justice tout comme la tribune des 3000
qui suite au suicide d'une jeune
magistrate alerté sur l'urgence de
réformé en profondeur l'institution or
votre projet de loi se contente de gérer
la pénurie pour tenir vos engagements de
recruter plus et plus vite vous brader
la formation des magistrats ou vous
attaquez à l'inamovibilité et
l'indépendance des juges pour pallier le
manque de personnel vous généralisez la
dématérialisation téléconsultation en
garde à vue audience en visio caméra
piéton pour les surveillants
pénitentiaires nous voulons une justice
de qualité vous prenez une justice
déshumanisée face au manque de personnel
de justice vous révisez à la baisse les
standards de nos droits fondamentaux ou
régularisez d'un trade plume les vis de
procédure vous étendez les perquisitions
de nuit vous élargissez les écoutes à
tout objet connecté mais pas un mot dans
votre texte sur la régulation carcérale
rien sur la revériorisation des métiers
de justice
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont les
greffiers qui ont manifesté aujourd'hui
à travers toute la France et notamment à
la Réunion je suis élue pour demander
plus de reconnaissance de leur métier
sans qu'il la justice ne peut pas
fonctionner à la Réunion également ou
les commissaires de justice ont inutile
un mouvement de retrait de l'activité
pénale pour dénoncer la dévalorisation
de leur mission nous prenons donc acte
de votre loi de gestion et regrettons
l'absence de vision structurelle pour
une justice de qualité là où vous ne
voyez qu'une justice de quantité la
tribune des 3000 dénonçait l'approche
gestionnaire de la justice aujourd'hui
malheureusement rien n'a changé vous
restez sourd à nos alertes j'en veux
pour preuve nos amendements quasiment
tous rejetés en commission et notamment
ceux qui concerne l'Outre-mer les
violences intrafamilales pour la réunion
ou le crime organisé en Guyane ces
territoires ou la justice souffrent
encore plus qu'ailleurs de manque ou les
justiciables sont encore plus éloignés
de la justice
vous restez sourd également au cri de
ceux qui manifestent mais nous resterons
donc fidèles à nos convictions à notre
attachement au service public notamment
au service public de la justice
respectueux des femmes et des hommes qui
inlassablement se dévot à la tâche nous
continuerons de défendre notre vision de
la justice celle qui place les droits de
l'homme au sommet de la pyramide des
normes et qui écrit la justice avec un J
majuscule
pour le groupe horizon madame la
Présidente Naima Moutchou
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sommets rapporteurs mes chers
collègues je veux d'abord redire ma
solidarité à l'égard de la famille des
proches de ce jeune sapeur-pompier qui a
perdu la vie cette nuit dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions évidemment exprimait
mon soutien à l'endroit de tous ceux qui
ont été en première ligne et qui ont été
pris pour cible pendant les émeutes au
premier rang desquels les forces de
l'ordre les mères les personnels de
justice
ils ne sont pas n'importe quel public
ils ont été attaqués parce qu'ils sont
les symboles de l'autorité mais cette
crise ou cette défiance de l'autorité
qui s'est manifestée n'est qu'un
symptôme ce qui est en train de se
passer dans notre pays et plus profond
n'est pas nouveau et ne sera pas sans
répercussion je vous le dis car j'avais
insisté à l'occasion du garde des sceaux
il y a dix jours avant les émeutes sur
une chose importante qui prend un sens
particulier dans l'épreuve que nous
traversons j'avais insisté sur l'immense
responsabilité de tous ceux qui plutôt
que de défendre la justice remise en
cause on critiquait dans une attitude de
critique gratuite pour certains avec un
accent nihiliste
tout cela ont des légit on délégitimes
nos institutions ils ont des légitimes
et la justice et partant ils ont donné
de la voix à la force et à la violence
et pourtant il n'y a pas de pays qui
tiennent sans ordre et sans justice et
alors que nous devrions faire front
commun aujourd'hui appelé collectivement
à l'apaisement certains préfèrent encore
souffler sur les braises je le dis c'est
indigne
vouloir tirer un bénéfice politique du
désordre d'abord c'est dangereux et
c'est une erreur et les Français le
prouvent les Français appellent au
retour au calme
et je dis même que concernant une
poignée d'entre eux pensaient pouvoir
faire je le dis comme je le pense du
clientélisme électoral sur le dos des
habitants des quartiers c'est une honte
absolue
notre responsabilité mes chers collègues
notre responsabilité d'hommes et de
femmes politiques c'est de dire la
vérité c'est de créer des perspectives
c'est de donner de l'espoir et
certainement pas de faire son beurre sur
le chaos
c'est ce que nous faisons et nous le
démontrons encore aujourd'hui en
débattant sur des textes importants qui
visent à améliorer le fonctionnement de
la justice
le constat du comité des États généraux
d'une justice mal en point ça n'est pas
une surprise et d'ailleurs nous n'avons
pas attendu puisque les réformes
successives qui ont été engagées
budgétaires et de fonds commencent à
porter leur fruit ce sera long chers
collègues il faut le dire ce sera long
on ne revient pas sur 30 ans sur 40 ans
de retard de sous-investissement dans la
justice en un coup de baguettes magiques
je me réjouis pour ma part que ces
projets de loi viennent offrir de
nouveaux moyens pour la justice avec un
budget historique porté après de 11
milliards d'euros d'ici 4 ans soit une
hausse de 60%
60% entre 2017 et 2027 c'est du jamais
vu alors on peut toujours trouver ça
insuffisant bien sûr mais on peut dire
aussi et c'est au moins aussi vrai que
personne ne l'avait fait avant à côté de
ses moyens il est question de réformer
la justice pénale civile et économique
le pénal d'abord qui sera certainement
évidemment la discussion la plus longue
nous soutiendrons par voie d'ordonnance
pour codifier à droit constant le code
de procédure pénale dans un cadre qui
permettra d'associer députés des
sénateurs c'est indispensable de le
faire pour l'exercice au quotidien des
acteurs de la justice et c'est une
opportunité que nous devons saisir
l'article 3 lui est dans les avancées en
termes d'efficacité de l'enquête sont
évidemment intéressantes il faut que les
enquêteurs et les moyens d'agir et nous
soutiendrons les mesures pourvu qu'un
équilibre soit préservé avec l'exercice
des droits de la défense plus largement
des libertés nous serons attentifs aux
protections accordées en matière de
déclenchement à distance des moyens de
communication et je défendrai pour ma
part des amendements sur la
téléconsultation médicale regarde à vue
à propos de l'expérimentation des
tribunaux des affaires économiques nous
savons qu'elle suscite des inquiétudes
avec mon collègue rapporteur Philippe
Pradal nous estimons qu'il y a
certainement matière à redéfinir un peu
plus le périmètre exclus les
associations loi 1901 intégrer les
agriculteurs à la formation du jugement
c'est pour nous important nous serons
également vigilants sur les garanties
qui pourraient être accordées en matière
de dégudiciarisation des procédures de
saisie des rémunération enfin le projet
de loi organique concerne le statut des
magistrats nous offre une occasion de
nous projeter bien au-delà de son
caractère technique c'est un texte qui
pose des questions politiques
importantes qui ne sont pas sans
incidence nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre en résumé pour conclure en lui
donnant les moyens d'assumer ses
missions ces deux projets de voix
replacent la justice au centre du jeu
démocratique l'actualité nous montre
combien nous en avons éminemment besoin
le groupe horizon votre asset texte je
vous remercie merci madame la Présidente
dernière député pour la discussion
générale et pour 5 minutes madame Ménard
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues Orange
mécanique c'est la couleur qui tâche
aujourd'hui le bleu le blanc et le rouge
du drapeau français un drapeau arraché
piétiné et brûlé par des émeutiers ivres
de rage des émotiers qui embrassent
depuis 6 nuits la France
déferlant dans nos villes arnacher de
leur haine de la France et de tout ce
qui la représente depuis la mort de Naël
une haine qui n'attendait qu'un prétexte
pour se déverser en bas de chez nous
sous nos fenêtres carcasse de voiture
enflamme mairie et école brûlées bus et
tramway embrasé magasin pillés policiers
grièvement blessé mère et même leur
famille agressées ce spectacle
apocalyptique est inacceptable
intolérable un pardonnable car nul n'est
dupe cette haine n'est pas crié au nom
de Naël bien sûr que non à la Devèze à
Béziers une cinquantaine de gamins ont
dévasté leur propre quartier ou 150
millions ont été investis pour le
bien-être de 4000 habitants ils ont
gravement détérioré la Mission Locale
d'Insertion faite pour eux comme dans
beaucoup de communes la poste des
commerces ont subi de des dégâts
considérables la mairie annexe a été
saccagée des véhicules ont été brûlés la
maison de quartier celle qui accueille
leur petit frère ou leur petite sœur
pour les centres de loisirs a été
les policiers nationaux et municipaux
les gendarmes et les pompiers ont malgré
les très nombreuses attaques et j'ai de
projectiles fait preuve d'un sang-froid
qui les honorent pour tenter de rétablir
le calme toutes les conditions étaient
pourtant réunies pour se faire du flic
c'était l'objectif aller à la
confrontation au clash au meurtre même
les images parlent d'elles-mêmes quand
des hommes cagoulés s'acharnent à
tiraient dans le dos d'un policier à
coups de mortier dans le dos oui quel
bravoure les milliards injectés depuis
40 ans dans les cités n'ont visiblement
servi à rien
séparatisme impunité laxisme et
irresponsabilité des parents sont les
grands mots de notre époque des engagés
face à cela la justice doit frapper un
grand coup une justice réellement
courageuse qui n'aurait pas peur
d'emprisonner les coupables dans les
15000 places de prison promise depuis
trop longtemps où sont-elles monsieur le
ministre
d'exécuter les peines au lieu de trop
souvent les troquer contre des remises
de peine et des tiges de faire de la
véritable réinsertion au lieu de lâcher
là encore trop souvent dans la nature
des personnes sans trop géniaux
d'expulser les étrangers en fin ce qui
n'acceptent pas nos règles et qui à
coups de délits et de crimes n'en
finissent plus de pourrir la vie des
Français et il est vrai que pour cela
les 10 milliards prévus et le
recrutement de 1500 magistrats d'ici
2027 vont dans la bonne direction mais
parce qu'une bonne réforme ne peut être
que comptable ne peut pas être que
comptable plus que jamais il est urgent
d'en finir avec l'excuse de minorité car
ne soyons pas dupe ceux qui conduisent
sans permis des voitures à toute allure
au risque d'écraser des passants ce qui
pillent des magasins pour récupérer une
paire de basket de marque ceux qui brûle
la voiture de leurs voisins ceux qui
veulent faire la peau à nos forces de
l'ordre cela ne sont pas des enfants et
il faut les stopper dans leur sentiment
de toute puissance pour ne pas dire de
sauvagerie hier dimanche à Béziers deux
jeunes ont été jugés pour des jets de
projectiles sur nos forces de sécurité
le premier à 17 ans il a été placé sous
contrôle judiciaire sans pointage avec
interdiction de paraître dans un
attroupement interdiction de sortir
entre 22h et 6h sans représentant légal
et interdiction de porter une arme
encore heureux le second à 14 ans il a
été condamné à des mesures éducatives
judiciaires à une interdiction de sortir
sans ses parents entre 22h et 6h et une
interdiction de participer à des
manifestations croyez-vous que cela va
les arrêter monsieur le ministre
car ces jeunes caillasses chaque nuit
pompier et policiers au risque
parfaitement compris et assumé de
blesser gravement voir de tuer ce qu'il
considère comme des ennemis durant ces
quelques jours de chaos une vidéo a
circulé montrant un père allant
récupérer son gamin au milieu des
émeutiers et le jeter dans le coffre de
sa voiture pour le ramener chez lui je
m'étonne simplement d'une chose Monsieur
le Ministre qu'il n'y en ait eu qu'un où
sont les autres parents où sont-ils ceux
qui ne s'étonnent pas de voir sortir
leurs adolescents tout de noir vêtus et
revenir quelques heures plus tard en
empestant l'essence il faut que l'État
dans toute sa force face son grand
retour de toute urgence il doit se
positionner avec fermeté du côté de la
justice lui redonner les moyens d'agir
avec des moyens humains mais aussi des
consignes claires et adaptés à
l'évolution de notre société ce
rendez-vous c'est le nôtre ne le
manquons pas la justice doit être rendue
pour tous et pas seulement pour Noël
merci madame la députée
la discussion générale communéclose et
je crois que le garde des sceaux soit
fait prendre la parole je l'ai lui cède
sur le rapporteur après le garde merci
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur
madame la rapporteur pour avis mesdames
et messieurs les députés
Jean-Jacques Urvoy savait parler de
clochardisation
Jean-Marc Sauvet a parlé de délabrement
et ce sont des mots que
je reprends à mon compte
30 ans d'abandon politique budgétaire et
humains je pense que nous en convenons
tous
et j'ai senti au-delà des divergences
qui sont les nôtres
et il y en aura et ça n'est pas
illégitime une volonté commune sur tous
les bancs de donner davantage de moyens
à notre justice car c'est ça
la principale
interrogation
de ce texte et la principale réponse
qu'il convient de faire
en magistrat
au greffier
à tous ceux qui font vivre la justice
dans notre pays
oui je sens cette volonté
transpartisanale d'améliorer la
situation de notre justice sauf
mais je n'en suis pas surpris
sur les bancs
au rendez-vous
comme d'habitude d'une hélice au total
au fond je le savais parce que vous êtes
pour tout ce qui est contre et contre
tout ce qui est pour
et vous nous proposez une motion de
rejet c'est-à-dire que vous ne souhaitez
même pas que nous allions plus avant
dans ce texte
et
vous êtes ceux qui aspiraient au débat
parlementaire un an plus finir tout en
déposant d'ailleurs des milliers
d'amendements pour ne pas qu'il ait lieu
c'est extraordinaire et là on en parle
même pas il y a 8 mois
de réunion avec des magistrats des
greffiers des personnels administratifs
des forces de sécurité intérieure des
avocats tout ce que la justice compte de
gens qui œuvrent au quotidien pour elle
et vous rejetez ça avec une forme de
mépris et de condescendance vous êtes
vous êtes au rendez-vous au rendez-vous
de vos habitudes délétères le grand
conducteur mélangeant je veux vous le
rappeler et ça signe la façon dont il
aime la justice et la police a été
définitivement condamné pour avoir
physiquement bousculé policiers et
magistrats je veux quand même vous le
rappeler maintenant écoutez bien il a
tardé à condamner ce qui nous a tous
bouleversé et non seulement il a tardé à
condamner ce qui nous avait tous
bouleversé mais il a dit touchez pas à
l'école bibliothèque gymnase ah bon
et les palais de justice et les
commissariats
et les mairies tout ça vous vous en
moquez parce que vous voulez vous voulez
que vous voulez détruire la s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît
le garde des sols à la parole seul le
garde de saut à la parole et vous le
laissez terminer
merci de laisser le garde des sceaux
terminés son intervention mesdames et
messieurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés je me suis rendu
je me suis rendu au tribunal de
proximité Daniel
saccagé
un vigile a failli être brûlé aucun
d'entre vous la condamné cet acte
les personnels les personnels les
personnels étaient les personnels
madame Martin vous n'avez pas la parole
son propos
allez-y monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président les personnels
étaient
s'il vous plaît écoutez vous
voilà vous laissez le garde de saut
terminé son propos vous aurez
l'après-midi même devait se tenir une
audience de surendettement pour nos
compatriotes les plus modestes
et puis on va aller encore un peu plus
loin et et souffrait que je vous réponde
et si ça vous plaît pas c'est exactement
la même chose
vous évoquez de façon
totalement partial la question des
greffiers j'ai dit au greffier depuis
des mois que dans un calendrier dédié il
y aurait naturellement des améliorations
que je porterai et j'ai dit que cela se
ferait à l'automne nous sommes le 3
juillet peut vous importe allons plus
loin si vous le voulez bien vous
raconter monsieur bernalicis partout sur
les plateaux que le budget de la justice
serait ridicule par rapport à celui de
la police mais regardez le nombre
d'agents des deux ministères et arrêtez
de raconter vos salades
et arrêtez de raconter vos salades
toute dernière chose parce que
je pourrais vous répondre pendant des
heures mais nous avons tous envie de
continuer sur ce texte de l'examiner
vous la montrer je répondrai nous ferons
un exercice démocratique digne desquels
duquel vous vous êtes délibérément exclu
en début de séance mais je vais vous
dire une dernière chose Monsieur
bernalicis je savais que vous parliez
mal je savais que vous pensiez mal je
viens de découvrir que vous chantez mal
aussi
bien